Das war's für heute. Vielen Dank für's Zuhören und bis zum nächsten Mal!
Moin, Leute! Hey, was heißt Moin? 15.50, Kegweight. Ich muss jetzt übrigens mal, gerade wenn noch nicht so viele da sind, ich muss jetzt mal eine Runde Microsoft flamen.
Und zwar, ich mein, was soll das denn? Warum ist mein Startmenü in letzter Zeit schwarz? Also nichts gegen die Farbe schwarz, muss man ja heutzutage immer dazu sagen.
Aber was soll das denn? Warum ist das schwarz? Ich versteh's nicht. Das war die ganze Zeit, war das hell. Ich mag mein Startmenü gar nicht dunkel.
Übrigens, ich weiß gar nicht, ob es auf diesem Account auch schon so war, aber auf meinem Hauptaccount. So, und wisst ihr, was ich dann festgestellt hab?
Auwele, danke für den HiIQ-Sub. Passt mal auf, was ich festgestellt hab. Wenn man hier auf personal, wobei es viel besser, viel besser, wenn man nach themes sucht.
So, pass mal auf. Also, was man machen kann ist... Sieht so kacke aus. Hallo? Ja. Also, was man machen kann ist... Also, ich hab keine Ahnung, was Microsoft sich dabei wieder gedacht hat.
Was man sagen kann ist... Default App Mode. Das sorgt dann dafür, dass hier so die... Beim Chrome die Bar oben hell ist oder so. Aber natürlich hält sich das Taskmenü nicht daran.
Was Default App Mode ist. Ich würde mal sagen, das ist ein Bug, weil das war vorher so. Jetzt zeige ich euch aber was noch viel, viel, viel besser ist.
Also, wo noch viel mehr Chebat von Microsoft ist. Wenn man sagt, ok, ich möchte eigentlich Windows Light Theme haben, aber Custom Color in der Taskleiste.
Passt mal auf. Ihr seht das hier? Ich kann hier Custom Color einstellen und so. Kein Problem, kein Problem. Jetzt kommt's, passt auf. Default Mode Light.
Jetzt kannst du einfach das Häkchen immer machen. Entweder du bist mit der Default Farbe zufrieden oder nicht. Also, warum gibt es hier nicht die Möglichkeit eine andere Farbe einzustellen, wenn man auf Light Theme stellt?
Das ist total hängen geblieben. Wer hat sich das bei Microsoft überlegt? Das ist auch kein Bug, das ist Absicht. Das ist Absicht, das ist Absicht.
Früher gab es ja auch keine Auswahl. Ja und? Das macht es doch nicht besser. Jetzt kann man das hier natürlich zurückschalten auf Dark und jetzt kann ich hier wieder Custom Color machen.
Also, es ist schon reichlich hängen geblieben. Also, das muss jetzt echt bei allen verstehen. Und vor allem, was ich gar nicht verstehe, warum hält sich die Taskleiste nicht daran, dass Default App Mode Light ist?
Es ist wir, es ist einfach so wir. Was hat sich Microsoft denn da wieder dabei gedacht? So, Chat, ich gucke jetzt mal kurz. Also, was habe ich denn hier übersehen?
Wir machen heute übrigens richtig mega, nein, Explorer Neustart. Hyper Big Brain Zeug. Da weiß ich selbst nicht, ob das funktioniert.
Der Stream heute gesponsert von Hetzner. Ausrufezeichen Hetzner in den Chat. Gibt es nämlich gleich Neuigkeiten zu verkünden, zeige ich euch gleich alles.
Also, ich gucke jetzt mal kurz in den Chat gucken. Uhrzeit wie so. Die Uhrzeit ist doch optimal.
Warum benutzt du auf dem Desktop keine Linux Distribution? Also, was sind die Gründe für dich persönlich für den Windows Desktop?
Ja, na ja. Außer Gaming ist so ein Ding. Also, ich verwende ja einen Linux Desktop. Siehst du hier, da. Linux Desktop am Start. Ich verwende ja beides gleichzeitig.
Die Hauptgründe, warum ich Windows auf dem Desktop verwende, ist tatsächlich Gaming plus so Zeug wie Sony Vegas, wo ich mich einfach zu sehr daran gewöhnt habe, das jetzt irgendwie umzustellen.
Oh, sagte mal, soll ich auf Science and Technology bleiben oder soll ich lieber auf Just Chatting gehen oder soll ich auf die neue Softwareentwicklungskategorie gehen?
Ich bleib in Scientology. Poolstream, genau. Alles klar.
Seit wann ist die Taskbar eine App? Schon lange. Das Startmenü, na die Taskbar nicht, das Startmenü. Das Startmenü ist eine UWP-App. Seit Windows 8 glaube ich sogar schon. Auf jeden Fall seit Windows 10.
Okay, also ich wollte das jetzt hier jetzt nochmal kurz etwas ausführlicher beantworten. Also die Antwort ist ganz einfach.
Bei mir liegt es hauptsächlich an Gaming und an so Programmen wie Sony Vegas und solche Geschichten. Und was ich mache ist, heute Hetzner stellt es.
Was ich mache ist halt, ich habe mehrere Desktops und auf dem zweiten Desktop habe ich einfach Fullscreen eine Linux VM laufen. Mit allem, was man so braucht.
Also das ist für mich das Beste aus beiden Welten. Du hast Windows auf dem Desktop für die Programme, die nicht unter Linux laufen, für vielleicht Sachen, wo Hardware-mäßig nur unter Windows geht oder wo es mal besonders performant sein muss mit irgendwas, was auch immer.
Und Gaming und für alles andere wie Zeug programmieren, Netzwerkrahmen machen, Linux Server, Cloud-Geschichten und so. Dann zwittige ich einfach rüber auf meine Linux, vor allem wo alles so ist.
Das ist für mich das bessere aus beiden Welten und ich finde es ist deutlich einfacher, Linux unter Windows zu virtualisieren, als Windows unter Linux zu virtualisieren.
Und deswegen mache ich das so. Und muss ich sagen, ich mache das jetzt schon nie. Bestimmt. Keine Ahnung. Seit ich streame ist es doch eigentlich so oder? Also 5, 3, 4 Jahre oder so.
Ich glaube ihr habt es bei mir noch nie anders gesehen. Also ich mache das jetzt schon eine ganze Weile und ich kann damit eigentlich ziemlich gut arbeiten. Einfach beides parallel benutzen.
Es hat ja keinen Sinn. Es hat ja keinen Sinn zu sagen, hey, so aus ideologischen Gründen zu sagen, es hat ja keinen Sinn, man will jetzt nur Linux verwenden oder nur Windows verwenden oder was auch immer.
Ich hasse alles andere. Nee, ich bin der Meinung, man sollte das verwenden, was sinnvoll ist. Wenn iOS bei Mobilgeräten sinnvoll ist, dann iOS. Wenn es um Automatisierungsgeschichten geht, Android bei Mobilgeräten auf dem Desktop.
Wenn man Designer stellt, Audio stellt, sonst was machen will. Oder auf Mac steht, soll man Mac verwenden. Wenn man spielen will, soll man Windows verwenden. Und ansonsten für den anderen Kram würde ich alles Linux verwenden. Ganz einfach.
So. Ja, ich hab noch nicht geupdatet. Das kommt wahrscheinlich daher. Ja. Pork. Haben die Hammersteckleisten bei dir auch manchmal Delay oder hast du die zweimal schalten müssen, dass die reagieren?
Nein, das hab ich nicht. Du musst gucken, wenn du Tasmota geflasht hast, ganz wichtig, wenn du Tasmota geflasht hast, du musst Tasmota einen NTP-Server einstellen, der funktioniert. Wenn Tasmota keinen NTP-Server erreichen kann zum Zeitabrufen, spackts rum. Das ist wichtig, das muss unbedingt, sonst gehts nicht.
Ja, korrekt, das wird heute gemacht. Apropos Microsoft, gerade mal wieder bemerkt, dass Nick, was Nick Teaming unter, was ist der Nick Teaming, sowas wie Bond-Interfaces? Leute erhält mich, was ist Nick Teaming? Ist das sowas wie Netzwerkkartenbonding unter Linux?
Wahrscheinlich. Klingt, natürlich brauchen die da wieder ein eigenes Wort für. Was sonst? Teaming, also Bonding klingt irgendwie sinnvoller, weil es wird da zusammen gewickelt und aus zwei Netzwerkkarten eine gemacht, wobei das auch nicht so einfach ist.
So. Die sind umstritten, wusste ich nicht, dass die umstritten sind, jetzt ernsthaft, nicht weil Sellout-Modus, also ich hab wirklich, warum sind die umstritten? Ist mir jetzt neu. Mysterion, danke für den Sub, elf Monate.
Exzellent. Naturfreundlich auch am Start. Max, gibt es eine E-Crypt-FS-Alternative? Wenn ja, ne, kenn ich nicht, also ich kenn noch ENC-FS, gibts noch? Ansonsten fällt mir da nicht viel ein.
Silvercross, danke, der Mysterion hat gegiftet, danke für die Gift-Subziele, der Silvercross hat Glück gehabt, der Flash-Jump ist wieder am Start. Der heutige Titel stimmt nicht so ganz, ich mal euch jetzt mal auf, was wir heute machen.
Also, wir machen heute, mal gucken, ob das klappt, ich hab wirklich keine Ahnung, ich hab das noch nie gemacht. Noji-Bait, ich hab keine Ahnung, ob das funktioniert. Also, was ich mir gedacht habe, ist folgendes. Jetzt müssen wir erstmal ne Runde Werbung machen, denn Hetzner Cloud, deswegen geht CAC-WS-Service heute auch als Hyper-Mega-Startup in die USA.
Hetzner Cloud hat seit letzter Woche auch einen vierten Standort, nämlich in den USA, kann man das da unten ausblenden?
Äh, Twitter. Und zwar in Ashburn, bei den Jungfrauen ist das. Und die schöne Sache daran ist, wenn man jetzt wirklich auf die glorreiche Idee kommen sollte und man hat so einen beliebten Service wie CAC-WS-Service am Start.
Ich mein, wir wissen ja, dass das das nächste Millionen-Startup ist. Wer braucht nicht CAC-WS-Service? Wenn ich dabei war, ich zeig euch gleich, was CAC-WS-Service eigentlich ist.
Und wenn man das hat, dann kann man das jetzt über mehrere Kontinente spannen und besonders ausfallsicher sein. Das machen wir heute. Wie gesagt, mir ist neu, dass der irgendwie umstritten ist.
Genau. Es gibt jetzt vier Standorte. Finnland, zweimal in Deutschland, also Falkenberg und Nürnberg ist es, glaube ich. Und in den USA. Und wo muss ich jetzt machen? Weil ich weiß, dass Hetzner legt da viel Wert drauf.
Ich sollte vielleicht noch mal gesondert hervorheben, dass das Rechenzentrum in Finnland rein aus erneuerbaren Energien betrieben wird. Exzellent. So, jetzt haben wir erst mal instant genug Werbung gemacht.
Und was wir heute ausprobieren werden ist folgendes. Was ist denn schon wieder? Oh nee, ich kann mir... Ah, ich will mir die Deutschland-Trends gar nicht angucken. Gehste weg.
So, also was wir heute machen ist folgendes. Richtig, also wie gesagt, keine Ahnung, ob das funktioniert. Wie ich mir das vorstelle, kann sich jemand noch dran erinnern, was wir letztes Mal gemacht haben?
Wahrscheinlich nicht. Wir haben hier eine Web-Anwendung. CACW as a Service. Ich gucke mal, ob ich die gestartet kriege, dann kann ich euch nämlich auch erzählen. Ich glaube, hier ist es, oder? Ist die auf dem aktuellen Stand? Dann kann ich euch nämlich auch zeigen, was sie macht.
Wir starten das einfach mal kurz. Nein, falsches, falsches, falsches. Wir starten das einfach mal kurz, dann zeige ich euch, was diese höchst-advancede Web-Anwendung macht.
So, wenn ihr die aufmacht, bekommt ihr ein transparentes CACW-Bild, was random rotiert wird. Und wie wir alle wissen, so ein Service ist wirklich weltweit in hohes Demand. Also da hat die Welt drauf gewartet.
Das ist halt super Beispiel-Service. Das sind 5 Zeilen Web-Anwendung. So, das macht CACW as a Service. Und das, was wir das letzte Mal gebaut haben, ich versuche euch das nochmal kurz aufzumalen.
Das letzte Mal haben wir folgendes gebaut. Wir machen das jetzt mal hier mit Farben. Zack. Wir hatten einen Load Balancer und wir hatten 1, 2, 3 Application-Server.
Huge-Paint-Skills. So. Massive. So, das haben wir das letzte Mal gemacht. Und nicht etwa einfach nur Load Balancer, also das hat dann auch Zertifikat und sowas.
So, Domain war, wir haben sogar ein extra Domain. CACW.Services. Die gibt es wirklich, die Domain, falls das irgendjemand auflösen will. Ping. CACW.Services.
Ja, Dick. Dick müssen wir machen. Ihr seht, dass die Domain gibt es. Achso, ich habe kein A-Record bei Hetzner drin. Aber die Domain gehört mir. Die Domain müssen wir sagen, haben wir Sirius Max zu verdanken aus dem Chat. Der hat die sich mal geschnappt, schon in weißer Voraussicht.
Also, so haben wir das das letzte Mal gebaut. Und es hatte auch ein Zertifikat und alles drauf. Also kann man hier quasi mal... HTTPS... Doppel-Punkt... Doppel-Slash. So. Und wenn man da draufgegangen ist, ist man quasi randomized auf einen der hinteren Absurfer geload balancet worden.
Das heißt, wir haben CACW.Services-Service nicht einfach nur hier lokal betrieben oder auf einem Server betrieben. Nein, wir haben das sogar mit Loadbalancer. Gleich wieder... Nee, nee. Ich habe mich nicht eingeloggt bei dem Registrar. Nee, nee. Dein Name wird heute nicht geleakt.
So. Und dann haben wir... Oh nein, es wird der Song. Das hat mir heute noch gefehlt. Vielleicht laut genug. So. Und was wir dann gebaut haben, ist Folgendes. Wir haben eine GitHub Action programmiert.
Kann ich euch auch kurz zeigen. GitHub Workflows. Wir haben eine GitHub Action programmiert. Die on-the-fly, also quasi... Naja, Kubernetes-Lite ist da jetzt ein bisschen zu viel gesagt. Da ist es ja null dynamisch dran.
Aber dafür deutlich einfacher und besser zu durchschauen. Die on-the-fly, die Server deploit, wenn man eine neue Version pusht. Also wenn man jetzt eine neue Version hat von CACW.Services, dann wird erst der Server neu gemacht, dann der Server. Der Server und der Loadbalancer fängt das alles ab.
Natürlich hat das ja auch ein gültiges Zertifikat und alles. So. Das haben wir das letzte Mal gebaut. Und jetzt kommt... Ich hatte die Idee für die Erweiterung von CACW.Services, wo alle drauf gewartet haben. Vor allem im Hinblick dessen, dass Headsetz einen Standort in den USA hat.
Wisst ihr, was wir einfach machen könnten? Wir könnten das einfach verdoppeln. Und das hier. Das hier. Und dann machen wir das hier. Gehst du weg? Monka. Nein, nein, nein. Das soll Plau sein. Das soll Plau sein. Das da. Dann haben wir das da.
Und das hier ist NA. Und das hier ist EU. Und jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, wie kriegen wir das hin, dass das beides irgendwie funktioniert?
Also wir skalieren quasi vertikal horizontal. Das ist für die Noobs. Wir skalieren gleich wieder horizontal. Und wir haben jetzt zwei Standorte. Also wir haben Europa. Machen wir in Nürnberg oder so.
Haben wir hier vier Kisten. In NA haben wir hier vier Kisten. Und hast du Bock, meine Programmierhausübung zu machen? Mach mal einen Pastebin und schick mal her. Und jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, wie teilen wir das am besten auf?
Sprich, dass die Leute beides Services verwenden. Deswegen habe ich mir gedacht, das habe ich noch nie gemacht. Kann ich euch gleich sagen, kann ich sagen, dass das voll in die Hose geht. Wir werden das über DNS machen. Und zwar, was ich mir überlegt habe, ist beides ist erreichbar unter QQ Services.
Aber der DNS guckt, was näher an euch dran ist. Und dann kriegt ihr die IP zurückgeliefert vom Service, der bei euch näher ist. Kann dann mir geistig folgen. Also nicht PDF. Nicht PDF. Pastebin.
Einfach Text reinpasten, mir die Link schicken. So. Und was wir heute bauen, ist folgendes. Also wir haben hier, außerhalb gibt es ja einen DNS.
Massive Schreibweise DNS. Und der beantwortet ja, wenn ihr das auflöst. So und für alle User aus EU. Für alle User aus EU. Mach mal hier. EU User.
Für alle User aus EU kriegt man das da zurückgeliefert als Eingang. Und für alle User aus NA. Mach mal hier irgendwie mal keine Ahnung. NA User. Das können wir mit irgendeinem VPN oder so testen. Müssen wir mal gucken.
Für alle NA User, die kriegen das zurückgeliefert. So. Heute streamen. Was gibt es noch für Möglichkeiten statt DNS? Da gibt es ein paar Varianten, was man machen kann.
Die einfachste Variante ist, das kleinzeitig zu machen. Also sprich, dass man im Browser irgendwie eine Logik einbaut und dann einfach die Seite neu fetched von einem anderen Standort.
Die schöne Variante ist Anycast. Aber Anycast kann man nicht so als der hergelaufene Typ im Internet machen. Also Anycast ist zum Beispiel das, was der Google DNS macht. Nämlich die gleiche IP mehrfach auf der Welt.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das mal ausprobiert habt. Wenn ihr jetzt zum Beispiel so Cloudflare pingt oder Google pingt oder so, pingen wir mal Cloudflare oder irgendwie Google, dann ist das immer ziemlich schnell. Woran liegt das? Na gut, den DNS Server gibt es einfach mehrfach auf der Welt.
Und es wird geguckt, dass der Weg genommen wird, der halt zu euch quasi am kürzesten ist oder einer der kürzeren Wege. Also Anycast ist ja eigentlich die coole Variante, aber das kann man nicht machen, weil damit Anycast funktioniert, braucht man Router im Internet.
Um es mal ganz einfach zu sagen oder ganz simpel zu sagen. Eigene Router, weltweit unterschiedliche Router und einen Provider, der das dann dementsprechend annoucen kann. Der Provider muss dann annoucen, den Server gibt es dort und wenn dann quasi eine Anfrage kommt, dann sagt man ok, man nimmt jetzt irgendwie schnellsten Weg, also nicht günstigsten Weg vielleicht, sondern schnellsten Weg und dann wird das immer zum Server in der Nähe geschoben.
Das geht nicht so einfach, also Anycast kannst du schonmal knicken, so als 0815 User im Internet. Das mit DNS ist eine coole Variante. Leute, ich muss mal kurz Licht anmachen, es ist ein bisschen dunkel schon.
Also wir probieren das heute mit DNS und ich habe das wie gesagt noch nie in dieser Art und Weise probiert, deswegen, wir machen das auch selbst, wir machen das selbst. Also es gibt, bei Amazon gibt es Root, wie heißt der Amazon DNS, Root 53, also wegen halt dem DNS Port vermutlich mal stark, der kann das, aber ich habe ein anderes Produkt gefunden und das wollte ich heute mal ausprobieren, nämlich das hier.
Von der Idee her macht der auch sowas, ist sogar ein relativ beliebtes Projekt, wenn man sich die Sterne anguckt. Im Prinzip macht der auch sowas. Warum nicht die Bilder in ein CDN und mit einer Serverless Function zu einem random Build weiterleiten, das geht auch, es gibt viele Varianten, aber heute probieren wir mal die aus.
Was ist Java? Was ist Java? Ich hoffe nicht, dass hier irgendwas Java ist. Ach du im Chat, zeig mal her. Pastebin. Okay, Moment, wir gucken uns mal kurz, wir gucken uns mal kurz die Hausaufgaben von LoloFunt an, mal auf die Schnelle.
Monka alter, ne, das lese ich mir jetzt nicht durch. Iiih und außerdem es ist Java. Nein, das machen wir nicht im Stream jetzt.
Ich glaube so ist das nicht gedacht.
Sie dürfen sich austauschen, natürlich, wir gehen bestimmt alle mit dir auf die gleiche Uni.
Plagiate werden nicht akzeptiert und entsprechend geahndet. Ne, das können wir jetzt nicht machen. Das ist jetzt zu viel. Wahrscheinlich ist das auch ein bisschen schwieriger.
Ne, das weiß ich. Okay, zurück zum eigentlichen Thema. Wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben? Genau, und angeblich kann das diese DNS.
Man muss, das ist Go, das ist Go, also sprich man legt den runter, startet den und dann braucht man ein Zonenfile und da schreibt man dann sowas hier rein.
Sowas. Die Konfig habe ich mir angeguckt und habe mir gedacht, das ist doch relativ simpel, das kriege ich auch hin.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ich habe das noch nie gemacht, ich habe wirklich keinen Plastenschirm, ob das funktioniert am Ende.
Und wenn das funktioniert, so wie ich mir das vorstelle, dann kriegen wir am Ende bei einer IP aus den USA, wenn wir von einer IP aus den USA abfragen, eine andere IP aufgelöst als aus Europa.
Warum das Null ist, was auch immer. Wenn das vielleicht einfach DNS technisch Punkt nennen sollen oder so. Ich weiß nicht, das probieren wir jetzt aus.
Muss mal kurz in meine Notes gucken, ob ich irgendwas vergessen habe.
Wir haben sogar Paintbildchen gemalt. Das heißt, wenn heute die Leute reinkommen und fragen, und wie sieht es aus, was machst du, dann kann ich das Bild zeigen.
Da steht man zwar vielleicht auf den ersten Blick nicht, aber ja, IP League Incoming.
Tja, da habe ich vorgebeugt, dass ich nicht wieder meinen Router neu starten muss, da habe ich vorgebeugt und zwar, passt mal auf, wir legen uns jetzt erstmal einen Server für ein DNS an.
Eine Ahnung, hier. Nuremberg, Falkenstein, was auch immer, das glaube ich Nürnberg auf Deutsch. Ubuntu 20.04.
Wir nehmen mal einen Dreikerner, einfach weil es schneller von der Handhabung geht.
Und ich kann euch nur eine Sache empfehlen, wenn ihr euch das Ganze mal angucken wollt, Ausrufezeichen im Chat machen und mit meinem Gutscheincode 20€ Startguthaben abgreifen.
Aber was ich eigentlich sagen wollte, was ich euch empfehlen kann ist, startet euren Server damit, denn ihr könnt ohne Probleme nach oben skalieren,
ihr könnt aber schlecht eine in größer erstellte VM wieder nach unten skalieren.
Also wenn ihr die VM hiermit erstellt und dann hoch skaliert, ist das kein Problem, dann könnt ihr auch wieder runter skalieren.
Wenn ihr die VM aber hiermit erstellt und wollt ihr dann runter skalieren, dann funktioniert das nicht.
Warum? Weil die Festplatte größer ist.
Hier bekommt ihr 160, es sei denn ihr braucht natürlich den Speicher, dann ist wieder was anderes.
Hier bekommt ihr 160 GB SSD Speicher, hier 20.
Das heißt, wenn ihr hiermit anfängt und ihr dann sagt, so eine fette VM brauche ich gar nicht ohne neu aufbauen, wollt ihr die runter skalieren, dann funktioniert das nicht.
Weil, naja, 160 könnte ja mehr drauf sein als mit 20.
Aber zum Testen jetzt für unseren DNS mache ich mal eine Triple Kern Kiste hier.
Und was man übrigens auch schon ganz cool sieht, was im Vergleich zu vielen anderen Anbietern nicht so ist,
also zumindest bei diesen klassischen Anbietern, wo du den Server kaufst und schließt es dann ab für einen Monat, halbes Jahr, Jahr,
hier bezahlst du bei HetznerKlaut, bezahlst du stündlich.
Das heißt im Endeffekt, wenn ihr irgendeine ultrafette Kiste braucht, hier wenn ihr jetzt sagt, wir brauchen, ne, das ist doch zu wenig, gab es da nicht noch mehr?
Ich hab mich jetzt verwirrt.
Ah, hier ist es doch.
Also wenn jetzt mal einer sagt, ihr braucht 48 Kerne, 197 GB RAM, 1 TB SSD, dann könnt ihr auch den nehmen.
Und wenn ihr da einfach nur zwei Stunden was berechnen müsst oder drei, dann habt ihr am Ende zwei Euro bezahlt.
Also stündliche Abrechnung ist sehr poggers.
Ist bei Digital, ich weiß, das ist bei vielen Anbietern so, aber es kennen viele Leute nicht, weil bei,
ich will jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt jetzt hier die große deutsche Anbieter erzählen, aber das war lange Zeit so,
dass wenn du nicht bei irgendeiner dynamischen Cloud-Geschichte was gekauft hast, sondern irgendwo dir einen Server gemietet hast,
dass du dann erstmal einen Monat oder ein Jahr bezahlen müsstest.
Zumindest, es ist preislich ein bisschen teurer geworden durch diese IPv4-Geschichte, aber es ist immer noch super Preis-Leistung.
Und vielleicht spart man woanders ein bisschen was, aber insgesamt von dem Gesamtpaket bin ich wirklich zufrieden.
Und das ist jetzt No-Sell-Out-Gelaber, ich verwende den Gramm ja selbst ohne Kohle dafür zu bekommen schon ganz schön lange.
Only IPv6-Server, ja da habe ich jetzt Gerüchte gehört, das wird es angeblich bald geben.
Angeblich soll es sogar auch, aber Gerüchte weiß ich, also das habe ich von keinem offiziellen Verletzter gehört.
Was macht dein CACW Service eigentlich, da machen wir heute weiter, der zieht heute in die USA um.
Dass es eventuell bald VMs gibt ohne Public IP, was echt cool wäre, oder halt mit IPv6, das kostet ja nichts,
was echt cool wäre für irgendwelche internen Geschichten.
So, also, nehmen wir mal hier eine mit 3 CPU-Kernen, ich finde den hier persönlich preisleistungstechnisch am ansprechendsten.
3 CPU-Kernen, 4GB RAM, 80G SSD, klar, wenn du weniger Rechenleistung brauchst, dafür mehr RAM geht auch,
aber den finde ich eigentlich in Kombination am besten.
Der Preisschamp läuft übrigens auch backhand-technisch auf drei von den Kisten, reicht dicke.
Genau, ohne Public IP hinter einem LB, das wäre eine super Geschichte.
Oh, was ist das denn da oben? Maintenance Backbone Connection Frankfurt Helsinki.
Wir werden es überleben. So, wenn man Server anlegt, ganz einfach hier Faltenstein, Ubuntu, blablabla, größer auswählen.
Wie gesagt, ich würde euch empfehlen, fangt immer mit dem an und skaliert dann hoch und dann könnt ihr nämlich wieder runterskalieren.
Volumes Network brauchen wir nicht, Firewall können wir gleich anlegen, SSH-Keys, dass wir kein Passwort eingeben müssen.
Und jetzt, big brain time, dass ich nicht wieder ganzen IPs leake, ich habe hier mal was vorbereitet.
Bam.
Was das macht ist, nachdem der Server neu aufgebaut ist, deaktiviert er, dass die IP-Adresse angezeigt wird per SSH-Login.
Muss ich jetzt bei jedem Server machen, wenn ich den aufbaue.
Ich glaube aber in unserem Ansible-Skript ist das auch drin.
Big brain time, ne?
Squiz, ich sehe, dem Chat gefällt es, ja, nice.
So, schauen wir mal, ich baue jetzt mal die Kiste auf und dann legen wir uns meinen eigenen DNS-Server an.
Wir müssen während das Ding aufbaut, das gibt es nur für dich.
Hä? Ach so, ja, wahrscheinlich.
Wir müssen noch auf den, ne, Quatsch, Quatsch, hier, wir müssen noch im DNS ein bisschen Sachen anlegen.
Und zwar, was wir brauchen ist Folgendes, zumindest habe ich mir das soweit überlegt.
Ach so, ich weiß ja die IP noch gar nicht.
Doch, hier, IP.
Also, DNS-Server löst ja jetzt schon auf, halt, also, ist zuständig für CACW.Services, löst aber noch nichts auf.
Was wir jetzt brauchen, ist ein Eintrag für einen weiteren Nameserver, den wir selbst betreiben darauf.
Übrigens, mal ganz kurze Disclaimer, nicht nachmachen.
Es ist in der Regel selten sinnvoll, einen eigenen DNS-Server im Internet zu betreiben.
Ich sag's nur, ne?
Das ist rein zu Ausprobieren, Lernen und Entertainment-Zwecken, wie ich das hier mache.
Wenn ich das wirklich live betreiben wollen würde, dann würde ich entweder gucken, ob ich das hier irgendwie,
vielleicht haben die sowas hier drinnen, aber ich glaube, die haben keine DNS-AP.
Und wenn sie eine haben, dann geht's, dann geht's da drüber auch.
Dann würde ich auf jeden Fall gucken, dass ich irgendeine DNS, irgendeinen Anbieter nehme.
Ob es Hetzner kann, müsste ich mal gucken.
Der eben diese, ich glaube, die können es nämlich nicht, der so Geo-IP-Sachen eingebaut hat.
Gibt es?
Bekommt man nicht an 5 Minuten eine Mail vom BSI?
Nee, das ist dem BSI ziemlich egal, ob ich da einen Server hab.
So, ich lock mich mal kurz drauf ein.
Der hier, der hier muss mal kurz weg.
Root, add, bam, yes.
So, erzähl mal, ob's gegriffen hat, ob ich die IP leake.
Nein, ich leake die IP nicht.
Kommt mal, Leute, bam.
Es funktioniert.
Kein, kein IP-Leak, Poggers.
Update.
Nee, du bekommst eine Nachricht wahrscheinlich per Mail geschickt, wenn du eine DNS auf aber die Lokale im Internet hast.
Ansonsten ist das ja vollkommen legitim, es darf man machen.
Ja, dann sollste mir eine E-Mail schreiben.
Ich mach das Ding dann nach dem Stream wieder aus.
So, von der Idee her, was wir brauchen, ist Folgendes.
Wir brauchen einmal einen Rekord für unseren neuen DNS.
Den nennen wir...
Chat, ich brauch guten...
Also, NS wäre deutlich zu easy.
Ich brauch einen guten Namen für unseren DNS-Server.
Wer...
Chat, wir brauchen irgendwas Gutes.
Was zu uns passt.
Cute DNS.
Habt ihr eine gute Idee?
Name für einen DNS-Server.
Cute NS.
DNS-Champ.
Das finde ich tatsächlich gut.
Allerdings bringen den Kurz- und Kleinschreiben her natürlich nichts.
Keks.
Wie heißt die Ayaya-Dame?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Keks, Keks finde ich tatsächlich nicht schlecht.
Das machen wir.
Keks.
So.
Oh nein, Leak.
Das ist ja dumm gemacht.
Da hab ich Preis-Champ-IPs geleakt.
Was nicht wild ist, den Service schalte ich eh ab.
Shithub DNS.
So.
Joa.
Macht die TNL low.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Das ist tatsächlich sinnvoll.
Nicht, dass sonst viel Waren aktiv ist.
So. Also.
Warum macht das BSI sowas?
In dem Fall wüsste ich auch nicht warum.
Das ist ja vollkommen legitimer Anwendungszweck.
Sowas, sowas zu machen.
So.
Also wir brauchen einen DNS-Server.
Der heißt Keks.
Das sollt jetzt von der Idee her auch gleich auflösen.
Gucken wir mal.
Ping. Keks.
Punkt. Kekw. Services.
Hey.
Nee.
Dick.
Stimmt. Funktioniert.
Guckt. Bam.
Löst auf.
Erstmal schon gedickt.
7, 8, 4, 7,
4, 3, 1, 2, 1, 0.
Passt. Ist die IP.
Joa.
Ich gucke ja live drauf.
Da passiert ja nichts.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass der
DNS in dem Fall
der löst ja nur mein Zeug auf.
Wobei bei Amplification Attacks muss ja die Absender-IP faken.
Ja gut.
Spätestens wenn da irgendwie ein komisches Zeug macht, sehe ich das ja.
Wenn da ein komisches Zeug macht, muss ich ausmachen.
Und es funktioniert halt nicht.
So.
Ähm.
Okay.
Jetzt haben wir das.
Und jetzt muss ich mal überlegen, was brauchen wir sonst noch?
Jetzt brauchen wir noch ein NS-Record.
NS.
Wobei das mache ich erst, wenn der DNS da funktioniert.
Bevor ich den irgendwie hier in die
in die Chain da eintrage.
So. Also wir loggen uns jetzt mal auf
der Linux-Kiste ein. Oder sind wir
schon? Upgrade. Erstmal
updaten. Alles. Das ist immer das Wichtigste.
Und wir machen jetzt bei der Gelegenheit
gleich noch was. Wir machen eine Firewall.
Ist nämlich auch ein relativ neues
Feature, was es bei Hetzner gibt. Gibt es
erst seit einem halben Jahr oder sowas. Das ist
jetzt keine super sophisticated
Firewall, wie jetzt irgendwie
was weiß ich, von PF-Sense
bis sonst was. Aber für so einfache
Portgeschichten.
Ähm.
Ist das eigentlich ganz gut.
So.
Also was brauchen wir?
Das hier sollte man auf jeden Fall drin lassen.
TCP Port 22.
Weil das ist SSH.
ICMP sollten wir auch drin lassen.
So. Was brauchen wir denn als nächstes?
Ähm.
Bisher würde ich sagen gar nichts.
Dann nennen wir
die jetzt mal irgendwie
KekWFW.
Apply to
Server
Ubuntu. Den Server muss ich
ordentlich benennen, sonst finde ich den Kram nachher
nicht mehr.
Warum immer das
ICMP geblocke, weiß ich nicht. Der lässt
ICMP hier explizit zu. Das ist kein
Geblocke, der lässt es explizit zu. Ich finde
es sinnvoll, wenn man den Scheiß pingen kann.
So.
Ähm.
Ja ne, DNS mach ich noch nicht. DNS mach ich dann
erst, wenn ich den Kram drauf laufen hab.
Zum ausprobieren.
So. Jetzt benennen wir erstmal
meinen Server um. Der braucht irgendwie ordentlich
Namen. Ich weiß, kann man den nachträglich noch umbenennen?
Jawoll. Das ist
KekWDNS.
Name ist
was zum? Warum?
Minus?
Minus. Da heißt der KekWDNS
jetzt. Aber nennen wir die Firewall auch
noch um. Dass das wenigstens, wir wollen ja mal
nicht so sein, dass das wenigstens einheitlich heißt.
KekW. Warum ist es da erlaubt
und beim anderen ist es nicht erlaubt?
Versteh ich nicht. Was hältst du von
BSD als Server? Er ist eigentlich ziemlich
Pock.
Das ist auch so ein Satz. Den Kram
den versteht man nur auf Twitch, oder?
Was hältest du von BSD? Ganz schön
Pock.
Das versteht man
auch auf der Welt sonst nicht, Alter.
So.
Also. Sie sind auf dem Server am Starten.
Jetzt probieren wir mal diesen komischen
GeoDNS
da drauf zu installieren.
Ich brauch nochmal einen ohne
anonymen Stells.
So.
GeoDNS. Wie installiert man
den Kram jetzt? Wir brauchen auf jeden Fall
wahrscheinlich
JIT.
Ja.
Ah, guck mal. Es gibt sogar Ubuntu
Packages, wie es aussieht.
Packages für
Debian, Ubuntu Packages für NTP
Pool.
FromStores können wir das ganze machen. Wir brauchen
Go installiert und wir brauchen mindestens
Go Version 1.1.5.
1.1.5 ist glaube ich schon ein bisschen älter.
Wann kam Go
1.1.5 raus?
Oh.
2020?
Ich hoffe
Ich hoffe, das ist
bei dem Ubuntu überhaupt dabei.
Search Go.
Welche Version haben wir da?
Was zum?
Ah.
Hilfe.
So viel Zeug.
Monka.
Oh.
Shit.
Weird Champ.
Das ist zu alt.
Das ist zu alt. Das können wir nicht verwenden
unter Ubuntu.
Ja, outdated, overrated,
debated.
Oh.
Hm.
Wir können
Docker Container nehmen.
Ich weiß,
wisst ihr was wir machen?
Ich hab die Idee.
Ich hab die Idee. Wir nehmen einfach nicht Ubuntu.
Wir nehmen einfach was anderes. Ich hab ehrlich gesagt
keinen Bock, mein Ubuntu zu updaten.
Keinen Bock, PPA zu verwenden.
Keinen Bock, den Kram im Docker Container laufen zu lassen.
Wir machen einfach einen neuen Server.
Was haben wir denn hier so zur Auswahl?
Ubuntu 20,
äh, nee, 18 ist auf jeden Fall.
Debian 11?
Hat Debian 11?
Was haben die für eine?
Äh, what the?
Nee, Buster ist nicht 11. Was ist denn?
Äh,
was ist denn Debian 11 Name?
Wie heißt denn das Ding?
Bullseye?
Was ist denn Bullseye Toy Story?
Wer ist das?
Aha, das komische Pferd da.
Tja.
Äh.
Ach, Quatsch.
Hier.
Ähm.
Ach, guck mal. Hier ist Go 1.5.1.5 dabei.
Probier mal Rocky.
Rocky, hab ich noch nie ausprobiert.
Ist Rocky Linux nicht das neue CentOS?
Rocky Linux 8 Packages.
Wir müssen erstmal gucken,
ob die
überhaupt das dabei haben.
Ist Rocky Linux dead?
Ja, das ist sehr dead,
wenn vor drei Monaten das letzte
Major Release rausgekommen ist.
Das ist, also ich,
also, ich hab noch
selten eine so tote Distribution gesehen.
Ja, keine Frage.
Ähm.
Dead Distro.
Package, Package Lists.
Installiert es doch aus den
ihren Repos, das wird garantiert
nicht funktionieren, wenn ich keine aktualisierte
Go Version hab.
Das wird's, das wird's nicht geben.
Das hat bestimmt Dependency.
Oh.
Ich würde sagen,
das für den offiziellen Repos hat sich
diesen Moment erledigt.
WTF, wo komm ich da raus?
Guck vor, um alles, was ist das denn?
What?
Hat das jemand schon mal gesehen?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was, was das sein soll.
User.
Den.
DBN11 hat Go 1.5.
Ja, ich will wissen, was Rocky Linux
hat, das interessiert mich tatsächlich jetzt.
Package Lists.
Was hat denn Rocky Linux
für eine Go Version?
Ich wüsste gar nicht noch, was ich da suchen soll.
Package Search oder so?
Schau auf dem Link, Zack.
Ach ja.
Rocky, Rocky.
Hat
1.1.5, ok, perfekt.
Und was ist mit dem aktuellen Fedora?
Fedora hat
34 hatten die, ne?
34, kam noch was anderes, ne?
Was haben die drin?
Die sind ja mit 1.1.6.
Ok, exzellent.
Dann erstellen wir uns jetzt einen DBN11.
Leute, Rocky oder DBN11?
Könnt ihr euch aussuchen, mir egal.
Rocky, Fedora.
Chat.
Wir meinen jetzt Rocky Linux, easy.
Erstmal testen, ob das überhaupt funktioniert.
Test.
User Data.
Moment, ich brauch mein Cloud Init wieder.
Cloud Init.
Create.
Ich bin für Doktor DOS, genau.
Doktor DOS.
Den brauchen wir jetzt unbedingt.
Warum nicht gleich
Solaris?
Die alte Variante.
So, schauen wir mal.
Was da jetzt angesagt ist, ja.
Das müssen wir eh gleich löschen.
Also, yes.
DNF ist das neue, ne?
DNF. DNF Search Go Lang.
Obbei, einfach installieren.
Einfach installieren.
Hier, go, steht noch nicht mal Versionsnummer dabei.
Install, bam.
App Stream.
Nicht Upstream, App Stream.
Oh, huge speed.
Massive Geschwindigkeit.
Ernsthaft?
Ich würde sagen,
das mit Rocky Linux hat sich gerade erledigt.
Nimm Debian.
Das mache ich jetzt auch danach.
Gut.
Vielleicht liegt es auch an den Hetzner Mirrors oder so.
Oder die haben dafür keine eigenen Mirrors.
Was auch immer, weg.
Bam, Rocky, du hattest deine Chance.
Aber du hast es nicht genutzt.
Delete.
Zack, bum, weg.
Ich muss sagen, und das sage ich jetzt nicht,
weil ich hier heute Hetzner Sellout mache.
Das Hetzner Webinterface,
im Vergleich zu so etwas wie Azure,
ist echt eine richtige Erholung.
Natürlich kannst du in Azure oder so mehr machen.
Das ist keine Frage.
Aber wenn du es denn machst,
den größten Teil der Zeit machst du da auch nichts anderes,
wie erstellen eine VM,
hängen ein paar Sachen dran oder so was.
Also das Webinterface ist wirklich gut.
Es ist logisch,
du hast an den passenden Stellen Autocomplete,
wo du es brauchst.
Und ich finde das richtig gut.
Also ich finde das richtig erholsam
gegenüber den größeren Cloud-Anbietern.
Natürlich kannst du auch nicht so viel machen.
Ich hoffe ja noch drauf, Leute.
Ich hoffe ja drauf,
dass, echt, ich finde das vom UI nicht schlecht.
Ich hoffe ja noch drauf,
dass Hetzner vielleicht auf die Idee kommt,
Männern Startenbanken anzubieten.
Dann haben die eigentlich wirklich
alles, was man so braucht,
zu 95%.
Natürlich kannst du immer noch sagen,
du hast erst mal simple Firewall-Regeln,
die vielleicht nicht für alles reichen,
aber es passt. Du hast Load Balancer,
ziemlich easy zu konfigurieren, verschiedene IPs,
Backups, Volumes.
Und wenn du jetzt noch managed
Startenbanken hättest, das wäre echt cool.
Oder GPU-Server.
Ja, es gibt so ein paar Sachen, klar.
Aber ich glaube,
wenn die wirklich noch managed Postkas
und vielleicht noch managed MySQL,
weil es gibt ja genug MySQL,
Hackermans, das wäre eine coole Geschichte.
Hetzner Kubernetes.
Ja, gut.
Dann bist du halt wirklich
bei vielleicht größeren Cloud-Anbietern,
aber da bezahlst du dich halt auch dumm und dämlich teilweise.
Habe ich euch schon
erzählt, Moment, ich muss jetzt erst mal
die VM anlegen in der Zwischenzeit.
Habe ich euch schon erzählt, was es
bei Microsoft kosten würde,
unsere Mail-Server
dorthin zu schieben.
Für SSD-Speicher,
was wir da bezahlen würden.
Das habe ich euch glaube ich schon mal erzählt.
70.000 Euro
im Monat. 70.000 Euro.
Oder 80.000 Euro.
Irgendwie sowas, ja.
Mega, also boah, das ist
wirklich hardcore.
Ok, Nürnberg, Ubuntu,
Debian wollen wir jetzt haben.
Du, du, du.
So, Cloud-Init.
Habe ich hier Cloud-Init irgendwo. Bam.
Create.
Recycle-Story.
Ja, Chat ist gut. Regt euch ab.
Der Chat-Lore ist doch gar nicht da.
Ok, jetzt
haben wir.
Debian am Start oder Debian,
wie das die coolen Leute sagen.
Man sagt ja auch nicht einfach Ubuntu,
sondern Ubuntu.
Etzer-Maschine ist noch die kleine. Ja, ich will erstmal
ausprobieren, ob das überhaupt funktioniert mit
ein.
Ob das überhaupt funktioniert
mit Debian.
Give IP.
Warum kein Fedora? Tja.
Warum kein Arch?
Hatten wir die IP schon mal?
Ach, die IP hatten wir eben. Lull.
Wie war das? SSH?
Ki? Ne.
Kigen? Minus R?
Rausschmeißen?
Aha.
Ok, Update.
Bam.
Zarex hat einfach warum kein Fedora. Das ist keine
Frage, die ich beantworten will.
Warum nicht eine
andere 30-Milliard-Linie-Distribution?
Upgrade? Gibt's nichts mehr
zu Upgrade? Ok.
Dann würde ich vorschlagen, wir machen
jetzt folgendes. Wir gucken
jetzt ab, install Go Lang
und
was brauchen wir sonst noch?
Go?
Warum kein Temple OS? Ja, das ist eine gute
Frage.
Ich meine 640 x 480
sollte ja eigentlich reichen und irgendwie
Build Essentials brauchen wir wahrscheinlich auch noch.
JIT?
Brauchen wir auch noch, genau.
Was? APT?
Spricht das irgendjemand so aus?
Sag mal,
die Viewer-Anzeige
bei Twitch kann sich auch gerade
ein entscheiden, oder? Die ist gerade von 180
auf 280
gesprungen. Und hier sind es 180.
Also Twitch hat wirklich keine Ahnung,
was da gerade wieder abgeht, glaube ich.
Can't wait.
So, jetzt haben wir
Go installiert.
Bei dir sind es 280.
Ey, keine Ahnung,
was da los ist wieder. Jetzt sind es
300, what the fuck? Das ergibt
keinen Sinn. Hab ich irgendjemand gehostet und ich
hab's nicht gesehen, oder was?
Creator-Dashboard
Zack, Zack. Ich muss jetzt mal kurz gucken.
Nicht, dass ich irgendwelche Hosts übersehen habe,
oder so.
Nö.
Aber Nütt, Nütt, Nütt, Nütt, Twitch
hat abonniert. Danke für den Sub.
iamjinks hat auch abonniert. 16
Pog. Richtig, ein massive Pog.
Viewbot hat geaktiviert.
Okay, wir haben Go installiert.
GIT brauchen wir noch.
Auf geht's.
Dann werden wir mal unseren eigenen DNS-Server
peilen.
Git-Clone?
Maybe Frontpage?
Nee, das glaube ich nicht.
xxpainxx, danke schön für den Sub.
So, cd, geo, dns.
Go build. Bäm.
Auf geht's.
Was?
Fertig schon? Nee.
Moment, das ist
irgendein Fehler. Oh nee, ich
hoffe nicht, dass da jetzt irgendwas
eingecheckt ist und das Bild broken ist.
Da hab ich jetzt wirklich keinen Nerv drauf.
Kann das nicht einfach funktionieren?
Die schreiben hier Go Version
1.1.5.
So, haben wir.
Okay.
Was ist das für eine Fehlermeldung? Package IO
FS ist not in Go root.
Okay.
Package FS ist not in Go root.
Package FS ist, wir fragen
Stack Overflow.
Wir fragen, was der letzte Comet ist, failed?
Soll ich
einfach, einfach einen...
Vielleicht mach ich einfach einen Comet rev...
Moment, die sind auf Go
1.7?
Was zum Teufel geht
dann da ab?
Okay, das ist, das ist irgendein
Pack.
Letzter Release Tag, ja, das ist
eine gute Idee.
Was ist denn der letzte Release Tag?
Ja, der da.
3.2.0.
Probieren wir es mal damit aus. Aber was ist das für
eine komische Fehlermeldung? Hier, zeig doch, zeig doch mal her.
Was ist das überhaupt? Was, was wollen die mir sagen?
Package is not in Go. Package is not
in Go root.
This Package requires
1.1.6.
Wir brauchen
ein neueres Go. War nicht
1.1.6 in Fedora dabei?
Leute, wir machen jetzt in Fedora. Scheiß drauf.
Ich probier das jetzt nicht weiter aus, wir machen jetzt in Fedora.
Easy.
Den können wir gleich löschen.
Wir machen jetzt in Fedora.
Easy.
Äh, hier, was weiß ich. Nur im Bash.
Fedora 34, äh
34.
3 Kerle.
Volume, Network, Firewall
Rules, User Data.
User Data, Cloud in it. Bam.
Keine Leaks.
Tests, Create.
Jetzt, jetzt aber.
Jetzt, jetzt, jetzt funktioniert's, Leute.
Easy.
Das hängt jetzt, das müssen wir abschießen.
Abschießen.
Minus R.
Fedora 34 hat Go lang 1.1.6.
Ja, das hab ich schon gesehen.
Deswegen hab ich das jetzt auch gepickt.
Let's go.
Okay.
Jetzt, jetzt kommt Fedora, stellt's.
DNF Update.
Warum eigentlich DNF?
Hat irgendjemand das mitbekommen?
Warum haben die jetzt DNF und kein Jam mehr?
War Jam zu oldschool, oder?
Haben die sich gedacht, Jam ist outdated,
debated, overrated?
Wollen, wollen nicht mehr, oder?
Weil Jam ist alt.
Ich mein, man hätte einfach, wenn man was Neues hat,
Jam durch das Neue ersetzen können.
Oder ist Jam schon
ein Symbolink auf DNF?
Yi, Kernel Updates.
Wer braucht denn sowas?
Das, das
Gaukelt er hier Sicherheit vor.
Mach nie Kernel Updates.
Kernel Updates, ja.
Für Noobs.
Einfach keine Kernel mit Fehler haben.
Load. Kernel Updates.
Load, genau. Brauchen wir nicht.
Ich verwende nur Kernel ohne Fehler.
Guck, ihm gefällt das auch, ja.
Dreht sich schon ganz wild dabei.
Nee, Suze ist nicht
Pock, ich mag Suze nicht.
Ok, DNF install
Golang.
Und, und No?
Und Git.
Wollen wir sonst noch irgendwas?
Yes.
Was? 739?
Boah, was zum...
Hat er da EMAX gerade installiert? Hab ich das richtig gesehen?
Ach nee, Pearl.
Warum installiert er Pearl?
Hat er da gerade wirklich EMAX
installiert?
Nee, oder? Ok.
Was zum Teufel installiert er, du?
Dann da bitte schön.
Go.
Mikurel. Hä?
Was?
Ich hinterfrag das nicht. Ich lass
den einfach machen.
Git hat intern einiges an Pearl, ja.
Das kann sein. Das stimmt. Das wird Git als
Abhängigkeit sein und nicht...
Ja, ja. Ihr habt recht.
Jett ist Massive Brain, wieder Jett hat Recht.
Muss ich auch mal zugeben?
Kommt ja sonst nicht so oft vor.
So, also
auf geht's.
Also
klonen wir uns das Ding.
Und hoffen, dass es jetzt funktioniert.
Natürlich alles als Root, so wie
sich das gehört.
CD, Geo, DNS,
CD-Bild.
Zack.
Ich logg mich mal kurz nebenbei ein
und mach mal... Ist nicht installiert?
DNF, install, Hardtop.
Ich will zugucken,
ob der CPU ordentlich
CPU-Auslastung hat.
Jett Core
macht Dinger.
Hat Go-Build nicht eigentlich eine
Ausgabe, wenn es was macht?
So Fetching from
Repo und
Building File 15,
15% oder so?
Drei Cores, ja.
Warum nicht?
Drei Cores ist
neues Meter.
Zwei Cores zu langsam, vier Cores zu
teuer, drei Cores beste.
Wieso nicht dreieinhalb Cores
ist jetzt die Frage.
Ja, Joke Gaming,
das ist wirklich ein Joke.
Er schreibt, auf der Arbeit wurden wir von
Kundengebieten ein Dokument zu unterschreiben,
in dem wir bescheiden, dass die Software, die wir ausliefern,
fehlerfrei ist. Ich glaube, man...
Das ist halt Fail. Ich mein, dafür
bezahlen will er allerdings nicht.
Es gibt ja die Möglichkeit, es hat ja Microsoft für Hyper-V
auch gemacht, dass du spezielle
Teile von deinem
Programm von Mathematikern
quasi verifizieren lässt, dass es keinerlei
Möglichkeit gibt,
dass Abläufe, also andere
Abläufe als vorgesehen auftreten.
Aber
es musst du erstmal so
programmieren, dass es geht. Also möglichst
wenig... Wie heißt das?
Funktionen mit...
Wie heißt das nicht? Seitenwirkung? Wie nennt man das
nochmal korrekt?
Also möglichst pure Functions. Also
wie heißt denn das korrekt? Chat.
Die ganzen Informatik
Studenten. Seiteneffekte.
Seiteneffekte, ja.
Möglichst wenig Seiteneffekte und dann von irgendwelchen Mathematikern
noch
verifizieren lassen. Kann man machen, aber das
wird der Typ bestimmt nicht bezahlen wollen.
Vor allem nicht bei irgend so 0815 Software, die es wahrscheinlich
war.
Aber es geht, ja.
Das hat Microsoft für Hyper-V auch gemacht.
Aber das ist natürlich
eine ganz spezielle Art und Weise.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das
praktikabel ist für normale Softwareprojekte.
So.
Ist das jetzt fertig? Hat das jetzt funktioniert?
Zack! Da ist er!
Da ist er!
Unser DNS ist am Start. Poggers.
Massive DNS.
Ich meine, wir können den ja lokal ausprobieren,
den DNS. Das ist kein Ding.
Also,
dig,
localhosts
and
localhosts, dann lösen wir mal auf.
Was wollen wir denn auflösen?
Was machen wir für eine Domain?
www, würde ich sagen. Komm.
www.cacw.services
Gut.
Also, manchmal
ist Fedora mir da schon fast...
Tja, gute Frage.
Was muss man da für installieren?
DNS-Utils oder so?
Install
Dig Fedora.
Heißt das wirklich
DNS-Utils?
Ach, tatsächlich.
Das gibt's wirklich? Hätte ich gar nicht gedacht.
Das war eher so ein
so ein Guess
in...
Aber cool.
Nice. Sehr schön.
Gut, da läuft
natürlich noch kein DNS. Wie startet man
den Kram jetzt? Also, zeigt mal her.
Oh, das
das... Flashbank
mich immer voll, wenn ich das aufmache.
Also,
geodns-interface
port 553.
Ne, das machen wir so nicht.
log-interface lassen wir weg. Der soll global
lauschen. Wir haben hier eh ne Firewall davor, die noch
zu ist. Haben wir ne Firewall davor, die noch zu ist?
Hab ich die angehakt?
Firewall...
...
...Resources.
Ja, hier hab ich
angehakt. Passt.
Also,
port
53.
Okay, und jetzt was?
Hab ich keinen Darkreader hier
oder so?
Warum nicht?
Ich hab den falschen Browser, glaube ich.
Lul. Sagt es doch mal
einer. Ich hab den falschen
Browser. So, und jetzt
hier, test-example. Gut.
Das da hinten können wir weglassen.
Add local
host. Okay, der
DNS funktioniert schonmal.
Alles klar.
Nur mit dem Unterschied, dass wir
test-example.com
nicht
abrufen wollen.
Okay, wie bedient man
das Ding? Ich hab's noch nie verwendet.
Ehrlich gesagt. Wir brauchen
erst einmal irgendwelche Files für
unseren CACW Services.
DNS slash... Okay, DNS.
Was liegt denn da drinnen?
Eine... Ich lösche mal alles,
was wir nicht brauchen. Wir können ja im Git repo nachgucken.
Test lassen wir da.
Makefile weg.
GeoDNS lassen wir auch da.
Wim.
test-example.json
Auch nicht installiert.
Also, da muss man
ihn mal lassen. In der Geschichte
ist Fedora tatsächlich
noch minimalistischer als
Ubuntu Server.
Okay, was haben wir denn hier am Start?
Seriennummer.
Time to live.
Max-House. Das ist wahrscheinlich mit wieviel
Houses zu antworten. Logging.
Targeting. Keine Ahnung. Kontakt
wollen wir auf jeden Fall nicht haben.
Data.
NS-Example.
MX. Nee, MX-Records
wollen wir nicht.
Hm. Ich hätte gern
so ein... Alter! What the fuck!
Ich hätte gern so ein Minimal-Example,
wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Ich muss erst mal alles rausschmeißen hier, was wir hier nicht brauchen.
Also.
Okay.
SPF-Records brauchen wir nicht. Ich weiß gar nicht, was SPF...
F...
SPF-Records. Hat das nicht auch was mit Mail zu tun?
SPF-Records.
Ist das nicht irgendwie was für ein Mail-Header?
Dass man irgendwie...
hat mich nicht...
irgendwie Spammer besser erkennt oder so was.
Weiß ich nicht aus.
Das benutze ich nie.
Ich bin eh nicht so eine große DNS-Experte.
Oder Mail.
MX-Records brauchen wir auch nicht.
Europe. Nee.
Europe.
Fuh!
Lassen wir mal eine IP drin.
Eine IP-Range da.
IPv6-Adressen
brauchen wir am besten nicht.
Wait. Was? Wie?
Weg damit. TXT-Records
brauchen wir auch nicht. ZIP-Records
bar 3211
ABC.
Ach du große Neue. Was ist denn hier?
Alias.
Brauchen wir auch nicht.
C-Names brauchen wir auch nicht.
Closest.
Das klingt noch ganz interessant.
Europe gelöscht plus 100
China-Chinesen Credit Score.
Das gefällt ihm bestimmt.
AAA.
Nee.
Quattrupple A.
Ach guck mal.
Hier kannst du sagen
Closest True.
Das heißt, der guckt dann,
dass er die IP zurückgibt, die dir am nächsten ist.
Oder so.
Wenn das so funktioniert, wie ich mir das vorstelle.
Moment.
Das ist die gleiche IP zweimal.
Sind die zweimal drin?
Closest True.
So. Fuh.
Also das heißt,
wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe,
dann starte ich das jetzt.
Eins hoch.
Dann starte ich das jetzt.
Und wenn ich da jetzt
testexample.com abfrage,
dann funktioniert es. Aber ich kann auch
fu.testexample.com abfragen.
Das funktioniert.
Okay.
Namensauflösung klappt schon mal.
Ohne, dass ich irgendwie planen hätte,
was ich da treibe.
Hier.
Closest.
Wie funktioniert das jetzt?
Also das ist klar.
So Closest. Also es gibt A.
Also das ist dann Closest.
Also wenn ich das auflöse,
dann macht er nichts.
Achso, das Ding läuft ja auch gar nicht.
Hä?
Der sollte, wenn überhaupt, immer nur
eine IP auflösen und nicht randomize.
So ist das.
So ist das nicht gedacht mit
Closest. Mein Standort
wechselt sich nicht. Mein Standort
ist immer der gleiche.
Okay, das ist dumm.
Oi.
Das ist dumm.
Was macht man? Was muss man da jetzt machen?
Okay, ich guck mir mal die Fehlermeldung an.
Oder falls Fehlermeldung beim Starten.
Zeig mal her.
Ne, sieht eigentlich gut aus. Opening.
Ach ne, hier guck mal.
Fail to find config file.
Stats, DNS,
config DNS. Ah, das Ding
braucht noch ein config file.
Also move,
geodns, geodns
conf.
Was?
Directory containing geo
ip2 mmdb
database files.
Was will der von mir?
Ricky, ich kann dir sagen,
was ich mache.
Guck mal, ich mach das hier.
Unser Ziel ist folgendes.
Wir wollen einmal unseren
Webservice in Europa im Rechenzentrum
bei Hetzner haben. Und einmal
im Nordamerikanischen
Rechenzentrum. Und jetzt soll der
DNS Server beim
Auflösen von keqwe.services
oder besser gesagt von
www.keqwe.services
soll der
je nachdem von wo du kommst
dir den richtigen Service zurückgeben.
Also sprich, wenn du von
Nordamerika anfragst, sollst du das hier
als IP aufgelöst bekommen. Wenn du von EU
anfragst, sollst du das hier als IP aufgelöst
bekommen. Da gibt es Services
im Internet, die das für dich machen.
Aber ich hab mir gedacht, wir machen
das mal selbst. Und ich hab keinen Plan
davon. Oh, Passwort Leak, Leute.
MonkaS, Anzeige ist raus.
Direkt Passwort Leak. Also
User Local Share Geo IP.
Hab ich da irgendwas?
User Local
Share Geo IP. Nein, hab ich nicht.
Ok.
DNF Search Geo IP.
Ach, Geo
Geo IP. Wenn man das jetzt noch richtig
schreibt.
Die Idee von dem
closest Ding wird sein, dass man mehrere
DNS Server in einem
Anycast Part, die jeweils unterschiedliche...
Also, das kann sein.
Wobei ich ja den Kram explizit
verwende, weil ich eben
kein Anycast machen kann. So als
0x15 Noob im Internet.
Also, ja, mal gucken.
Ach guck mal, da ist es ja. DNF
Install Geo IP.
Ach guck mal, und es gibt Geo
Geo IP Data.
Geo IP Lite
Data Extra. Ok, bam.
Alles, alles installieren.
Alles installieren, was geht.
Yes.
Gib ihm.
Geo IP.
Und wo liegt das jetzt?
User Local
Share Geo IP.
Nee. Ok.
Passt mal auf. Jetzt kommt meine
Poggers Repo Query.
Nee.
Ist das nicht so Repo Query?
Ich glaub schon. Jetzt kommen meine Poggers...
Fuck, ich hab vergessen, wie es heißt.
Hehehe.
Meine Poggers Kenntnisse. Wir haben ja
auf der Arbeit relativ viel Red Hat, ja.
Und ich dachte, ich kann jetzt glänzen.
Ist das nicht Repo Query?
Wie konnte man nochmal rausbekommen, welche,
wo die Packages?
YAM List Files
in Package.
Ist das Teamworks, was du benutzt? Ja.
Das ist doch Repo Query.
Ach, YAM
Utils muss ich installieren.
DNF.
Ach guck mal,
der installt auch DNF und Utils.
Ok. Jetzt kann ich nämlich sagen,
guck mal hier, was ich hier installiert hab.
Geo Data Extra
oder so. Das kann ich sagen. Repo Query.
Und ich glaub, List ist es.
Stand das nicht auch hier?
Screen? Nö.
Ah hier, guck mal.
User Share
Geo IP ist der Shit jetzt.
Geo IP.
DNF Provides?
Wirklich? Stimmt.
Stimmt. Bei YUM war es
What Provides, bei DNF ist es nur noch
What Provides, ne?
Probieren wir mal gleich aus.
Hier lernt man ja noch was.
Funktioniert nicht.
Ok, da ist es. Also.
User Share
Geo IP
EODL
Die Musik nervt mich. Sack.
Jawoll.
Ok, Directory.
User Share
Geo IP.
Starten wir mal, ob es jetzt geht?
Nein.
Failed to load
City DB.
Das scheint schon mal
nicht zu funktionieren.
Äh.
Was?
Was willst du?
Alter.
Geo Provider konfigurieren?
Was willst du von mir, Alter?
Wer hat sich das schon wieder ausgedacht?
Geo IP 2 gibt es nicht als Package.
Ich brauche eine
Datenbank hier.
Geo File.
Ok.
User Share.
Geo DB
Geo Type
Ich leg mir zum testen, wir machen jetzt was, ich leg mir jetzt zum testen einen Server an in den USA. Das ist jetzt ja neu
Ich muss ja ein bisschen Sellout im Stream machen. Das ist jetzt neu. Seit dieser Woche hat Hetzler einen vierten Standort, nämlich
Cacona Style in den USA am Start. Das heißt, wenn ihr schon immer mal euren Server entweder weltweit verteilen wollt oder explizit mal
einen Server in den USA braucht, vom VPN bis sonst was, dann könnt ihr euch bei Hetzner Cloud jetzt für 4 Euro, ab 4 Euro im Monat
könnt ihr euch in den USA easy VMs holen.
Freedom Server, genau.
Hell yeah, Freedom Server.
Guck mal. 2GB Asch
Wäre MaxMind eine Alternative für die Geo-IP? Was für ein Ding. Wer ist MaxMind?
Okay, ich muss jetzt erstmal gucken, wie der Klempel hier funktioniert. Also was wollen die denn von mir?
Was, was wollen die? Database? Database? Alter, was, was zum Geier?
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, was die von mir wollen, ehrlich gesagt. Moment. Wir suchen jetzt einfach mal nach dieser Fehlermeldung.
Fail to Load. Kann man bei Hetzner auch virtualisieren und z.B. Proxmox aufsetzen?
Ich glaube, dass es in der Hetz... also Virtualisierung in der Hetzner Cloud, das ist natürlich theoretisch möglich, ich selbst hab's noch nicht ausprobiert.
Aber nachdem das im Endeffekt auf nested Virtualisierung rauslaufen wird, weiß ich nicht, ob das so die Beste ist.
Ah, was ist denn das? Geo-IP-Asen-MMDB. Was ist das?
Ach guck mal, da ist der MaxMind, den jemand schon im Chat grad geschrieben hat.
Also das ist wieder so ein Thema. Es ist auch für mich, ich sag's dir immer, das ist auch für mich komplettes im Dunkelstorch.
Ich hab auch keine Ahnung, was ich hier überhaupt mache. Für den Fall der Fälle, dass immer noch jemand denkt, ich wüsste, was ich treibe oder so.
Also, wie ich schon oft gesagt hab, mein Video ist 70% der Sache ist Google-Skill. Samuel, danke für den Sub.
Pexter Geo-Lite-M. Oh, das haben bestimmt Leute schon gerippt und auf GitHub gepackt oder so.
Ah, exquisite, exquisite. Was ist denn das hier überhaupt?
Binary-Database. Free-Data klingt immer gut. Free-Data, Free-Data, da beschwere ich mich nicht.
Accessing Geo-Lite to Free-Data. Sign up.
Och nee, okay. Ten-Minute-Mail.
Ten-Minute-Mail.
Inzwischen-Ablage kopieren.
Zack. Full-Name.
Pog. Poggers. Pogchamp.
Industrie. Ad-Serving. Nee, Ad-Serving klingt immer so. Dating.
Chat. Next Tinder. Next Tinder lassen wir jetzt in der Cloud laufen.
Country-USR. Intended-Use. Web-Analytics. Mail-Adresse.
Das da. Perfekt.
Phone-Optionell. Null. Null.
Continue.
Was?
Sorry, we were not able to get. Please ensure that you are using mail. That is not the...
Oh Gott!
Oh Gott, bitte, nein. Nein! Nein!
Nein.
Was?
Citro.
Citro...
Citro Call of Duty
Alles klar
Citro, ah das ist so eine 10-Minute-Mail-Geschichte oder was?
Um zu starten geben sie bitte irgendeine E-Mail-Adresse in das Suchfeld an, klicken sie auf Button. Irgendeine E-Mail-Adresse
Q-Chat
Battery Quers
Achso da ist es
Keine Mails gefunden, okay also next
Next, sign up
Citro.de, continue
Der ist hartnäckig der Typ
Okay das funktioniert auch nicht
Müll-Mail? Was? Was es nicht alles gibt?
Okay
Nein Q-Chat
Jesus, Jesus.ru, bless RNG Alter
Jesus.ru, das wollte ich schon immer haben abrufen
Gekommene Time Alter
Jesus
Okay, lass mich jetzt please einfach registrieren. Ach mann. Lass mich registrieren Alter
Lass mich registrieren
Was jetzt?
Alter was ist das Problem? Ist das irgendwie keine Ahnung. Die nächsten Lottozahlen die in der Datenbank drin sind oder warum ist das so krass abgesichert. Weil das sind irgendwelche Geo-Geschichten. Das ist doch nicht highly wahnsinn secure
Ah
Was eine kacke mann
Oh fuck jetzt auch noch IP-Leak, ja wenn ich da weg bin dann gibt es wieder irgendwelche Leute die sich lassen können. Ach was eine scheisse mann
Okay, hier hatte das doch irgendjemand schon gerippt. Guck mal hier, das nehmen wir einfach das hier. Scheiß drauf da melde ich mich hier halt nicht an
So ich lad das jetzt einfach hier runter. Bäm. Copy link. Zack. MK dir. Geo
Weget. Was? Ach so. Weget. Alter. Gibt es da überhaupt irgendwas was bei Fedora standardmäßig dabei ist? Nicht mal Weget am Start. Weget. So next. Copy link. Bäm. Weget. Zack. Wenn du mich nicht registrieren lässt dann machen wir es halt so.
So okay und jetzt und jetzt gehen wir in die config-Datei. Geo DNS und sagen unsere Sachen liegen unter Geo. Hoffentlich funktioniert das jetzt.
Okay, okay, okay, okay. Es gibt keine Fehler mehr. Und es spuckt immer die gleiche IP aus. Das finde ich gut.
Ich glaube das funktioniert jetzt. So das müssen wir jetzt mal irgendwie testen. Das müssen wir jetzt mal irgendwie testen. If-config. Was haben wir denn hier für eine IP? DIDA.
Dick. Ach so. Moment. Bevor wir das testen. Ich brauche noch Firewall-Freischaltung. Und ich brauche noch CACW SSS-Service-Einträge. Ich habe hier noch gar nichts. CB-Test-Example.com.
Also was wollen wir haben? CACW.Services.json.
Ja. CACW.Services.json. Okay. Den Kram da oben lassen wir einfach so data NS. Ja NS wird dann. Wie habe ich das Ding genannt? CACS.CACW.Services. Nee. CACW.Services.
Du hast da einen Permalink. Oh nice, nice. Ich probiere das mal mit dem Kram, den ich da runter geladen habe. Aber wenn nicht, würde ich den nochmal anschreiben. Wenn du keine Zeit hast, dann kannst du dich auch abhauen, dann musst du dich da bleiben. Ich probiere das jetzt erst mal mit dem, was ich da runter geladen habe. Das dürfte ja auch relativ aktuell sein. Guck mal vom Februar.
Wobei, ob da die Hetzner-ALPs schon drin sind vom Februar? Das ist ja Ami-Datum. Das ist ja Februar. Also Moment. Ich muss jetzt erst mal hier diese komische Config machen und gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Also wir hoffen einfach mal, dieser Closest-Shit funktioniert. Machen wir das mal weg. Also Closest. Das heißt nicht los, sondern WWW. So und was für Server lösen wir denn da jetzt auf? Das können wir bei Hetzner uns ausbringen.
Wir lösen einmal das hier für Kokona auf. Wir lösen das hier für Kokona auf und wir lösen das hier auf zum Testen jetzt mal den Server selbst. Und wir lösen das hier auf für EU.
Und mit Closest sollte es ja eigentlich funktionieren, dass wenn ich sagen wir mal von mir daheim anfrage oder von dem Server selbst anfrage, sollte ich EU bekommen. Wenn ich von NA anfrage, sollte ich was?
Sollte ich die 5? Also wenn ich aus NA anfrage, sollte ich die 5 bekommen und wenn ich von EU anfrage, sollte ich 5-7 bekommen. Okay, probieren wir das mal aus. Was ist mit der Musik los heute gerade?
Okay, dick. Wir fragen jetzt nicht Testexampler, sondern www.services. Okay, wir bekommen die EU-IP. Wir bekommen die EU-IP. Das ist schon mal gut.
Was, wenn man das direkt aufruft? Ja, dann hast du Pech. Dann funktioniert es, aber du landest im Zweifelsfall auf einem falschen Server. Macht aber niemand ruft die IP direkt auf.
Dann müsste es das wirklich über Anycast machen. So, 1, 5, 7. Wir kriegen immer die EU-IP. Jetzt natürlich die Frage, ob wir aus NA was anderes bekommen. Okay, dann logge ich mich jetzt mal auf dem NA-Server ein.
Yes. Wir machen das gleiche, dick. Ich weiß, dass es jetzt übrigens nicht geht, aber ich muss nämlich noch Firewall freischalten, aber ich schreibe schon mal www.peqw.services.
Okay, das funktioniert nicht. Klar, weil die Firewall dicht ist. Gut, dann schmarr'n wir die Firewall auf. Was 2 Servers sind dahinter?
Ne, der soll da gar nicht dahinter. Der kann da auch dahinter, aber muss da nicht.
Okay, also DNS 53. Gibt es nicht DNS über UDP und über TCP? Ich glaube, ich mach da mal beides rein. Ich glaube, standardmäßig ist es UDP, ne? So, save changes.
Und wir bekommen die AMI-IP. Bam. Guck mal. Poggers. Das funzt. Das funktioniert. Guck mal, Geo-IP-Stells.
AMI löst so auf und EU löst so auf. Das ist ja geil. Das ist huge nice. Also, 5. Gut, RM. Dann schmeißen wir nämlich den Kram wieder hier weg.
Das ist Test-Example-Ding. DNS. Mit der Raub kopierten Geo-Division. Das ist eine Sicherheitskopie von GitHub. Da kann ich doch nichts dafür.
So. Brauchen wir den Mist hier oben überhaupt? Wahrscheinlich nicht. Max Hosts. Immer der returned.
So, ich würde sagen, das ergibt schon Sinn, was ich hier getrieben habe. Mehr brauchen wir eigentlich auch gar nicht. Mehr brauchen wir nicht. Wir haben zwei IPs. Ich meine, das sind nicht die richtigen IPs. Das stimmt nicht.
Anzeige ist raus. Das sind nicht die richtigen IPs. Aber es funktioniert. So, das heißt, jetzt. Okay, Moment. Jetzt muss ich mal überlegen. Was müssen wir jetzt machen?
Also, der Kempel, der funktioniert ja anscheinend. Jetzt würde ich sagen, jetzt wird es mal Zeit, ein Test-Webserver oder so zu machen.
Der einfach nur Hallo Kekona oder Hallo EU ausliefert. Machen wir das mal. Machen wir das einfach mal.
Was ist denn der einfachste Web-Server? Es gab doch so einen Python HTTP Web-Server. So ein ganz easy Web-Server mit One-Line. Da brauche ich nicht mal was zu installieren.
Was? Perl? Hier, das meine ich doch. Das meine ich doch. Ach, gibt es das in Python 3 nicht mehr oder was? Das muss doch geben.
Ah, Python 3 M HTTP Server. Ah ja, das ist, das ist, das will ich. Das reicht. Das reicht dafür. So, wir machen jetzt nämlich hier mkdir, keine Ahnung, www.
Alles, alles im gleichen Ordner, null. So, wir machen jetzt einfach eine Web-Seite. Also, das ist index.html. In der steht einfach nur drinne Hallo EU. Hallo EU. Und auf dem anderen Server machen wir das gleiche.
Mkdir, natürlich alles als root, was sonst. index.html. Hallo Kekona.
Das ist nicht HTML5 valide. Das stimmt. Das ist es tatsächlich nicht.
Struktogramm. Chat, das ist eure, eure Aufgabe. Struktogramm. So, das heißt im Endeffekt, wenn ich jetzt hier auf die IP gehe, wenn ich das richtig sehe. IP. Ah, Moment. Was ist denn 8000?
Hallo Kekona. Okay. So, das soll natürlich, das soll natürlich funktionieren über DNS jetzt. Okay, mal kurz, mal kurz in mich gehen.
Wir haben jetzt eine Web-Seite. Wir haben einen easy Web-Server. Okay. Wir machen jetzt noch eine zweite Firewall, dass wir das auch nicht machen. Das ist hier für DNS. Können wir das nicht auch DNS nennen?
FW, DNS. Und dann nächste Firewall. Das Ding heißt jetzt. Machen wir hier Port. Ach, scheiß drauf.
Brauchen wir nicht. Wir lassen den Server einfach im Internet hängen. Also den da haben wir. Den da haben wir. Das Einzige, was wir jetzt hier noch freischalten müssen, ist Port 8000.
Okay. So, wie mache ich das denn jetzt gescheit? Weil von mir lokal funktioniert das natürlich noch nicht. So, www.kek. Nee, das kann nicht funktionieren. Das kann nicht funktionieren.
Nennen wir das www? www ist doch ein doofer Name. Wir brauchen irgendwas, irgendwas besseres hier für den Stream. Das heißt nicht www. Das heißt.
Wo ist denn deine Domain gehostet?
Gute Frage, wo ich die gehostet habe. Ich glaube, die ist bei Namecheap. Was, ein A-Rekord auf die IP? Nee, das ist nicht das, was ich vorhabe.
Wie nennen wir das denn jetzt? Ich will, dass der je nach geografischem, wo du herkommst, den Unterschied andere IP liefert. Das passt schon. Das funktioniert ja auch. Ich muss jetzt nur das noch bei Hetzer eintragen.
So, www ist dumm. Wie heißt denn das? Geostells? Na, das ist mir zu lang. Cute. So, beste Domain. Global Stand. GS? GS ist gut. GS ist schon kurz.
Start. Dick. Also. GS. Funktioniert. Okay, wunderbar. Also, Sekunde, Sekunde. Kurz nachdenken. Also wir haben jetzt den DNS am Laufen.
Ich brauche das jetzt zweimal. Unten sind die Amis. Das hier ist.
Wenn ich den SWW. Warum habe ich das eigentlich in diesem Ordner liegen? Das ist doch total hängen geblieben. Move. DNS. SWW hier. Wenn schon hässlich danach ruht. Okay. So, jetzt müssen wir das eigentlich bei Hetzner einstellen.
Jetzt haben wir GS. GS. Queque. Okay, das heißt, wir gehen jetzt zu Hetzner in die in die Konsole. Wir haben den Name Server, der auflöst. Und jetzt brauchen wir eigentlich ein NS Eintrag.
Für. GS. Und dann auf Keks. Oder? Sechs Sekunden. Nee.
Ist es nicht? Ist es falsch, Herr Schmörer? Muss ich Keks. Queque. W. Punkt Services machen. Reloading Page.
NS für GS. Das macht er doch hinten automatisch. Keks. Punkt Queque. Ah. Okay. Wunderbar. So, das sollte jetzt von der Idee her, von der Idee her sollte das jetzt funktionieren.
Also, was jetzt passieren sollte, ist, wenn ich eine Abfrage mache an den DNS von Hetzner nach GS. Queque. Punkt Services.
Achtung, NS Eintrag. Das stimmt, aber ich glaube, das Ding ist so clever und checkt das automatisch.
Hetz Helium von Hetzner. Oh. Oh, ich hab's doppelt. Siehste, ich hätte es doch nicht doppelt reinschreiben müssen. Null. Save.
Okay, passt. Passt. Guck mal, es funktioniert. Es funktioniert. Der Lust, der sagt alles klar.
GS. Punkt Queque. Punkt Services. Antworten mit 7847. Ist das die EU? Ist das die EU-IP?
Moment, warum antwortet er überhaupt? Ich bin verwirrt. Ich bin verwirrt. Nee, das ist die IP vom DNS. Das ist die IP vom DNS.
Der selbst kann ja gar nicht antworten, weil. Okay, ich muss den. Okay, okay. Ich starte den DNS mal, ob das dann funktioniert. Wir machen das mal hier von der Ami Service aus.
Hä? Ich hab irgendwo, ich hab irgendwo einen Denkfehler drin. Ich hab, ich hab irgendwo, ich hab irgendwo Denkfehler. Vielleicht hat es sich auch nicht richtig propagiert, alles oder so.
Jetzt wende ich jetzt irgendwie nach, keine Ahnung, Bloop oder so. Ist doch eigentlich, eigentlich ist es doch richtig, was ich hier mache.
Der Nightbotchibated, der Flashchamp ist wieder da. Das stimmt nicht. Ich mein, das stimmt doch. Er sagt, all servitive oder wie man das einmal ausspricht, ist Kegs. Punkt Queque. Punkt Services.
Kriegsgruppe Keg. Queque. Punkt Services hat das hier.
Ach, das ist die falsche Server IP. Lull. Ich hab den doch neu aufgebaut als Fedora System. Das ist die falsche DNS, die falsche Server IP von dem Ding.
Ah. Gibbated. Gibbated.
Okay.
Okay, jetzt stimmt es aber, die Abfrage funktioniert. Ah.
Der, der machte Abfragen.
Der machte Abfragen. Das jetzt funktioniert, weißt du nicht?
Ich glaube, ich glaube, ich bin dazu Lowbrain für. Was ist denn jetzt, wenn ich sagen wir mal irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Cloudflare abfrage.
Das funktioniert. Das geht.
Bam. Ich frag von NA Cloudflare ab und ich krieg die, ich krieg die IP vom, vom NA Server.
Das funktioniert. Ich frag von mir ab. Ich krieg die IP vom EU Server.
Das funktioniert. Ist alles gut. Alles richtig. Easy. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Easy. So.
Jetzt fragen wir wieder irgendwelche komischen Leute an. So. Jetzt gehen wir auf den. Nee, nicht auf den Ami Server. Jetzt gehen wir auf den.
Auf den Finishing Server. Www starten dieses Python Ding.
Python Server. Python Server. So. Und jetzt gehen wir auf gs.kegw.services. Port 8000 und wir kriegen Hallo EU.
Perfekt. Hallo EU. Wie, wie kriege ich jetzt eine sinnige IP aus den USA? Wie kriege ich jetzt eine sinnige IP aus den USA?
Opera VPN. Wir können auch, wir können einfach, wir können NA Server mit x Forwarding machen oder so.
Wisst ihr was? Wir machen jetzt eine Sache. Ich wollte schon immer mal das Opera VPN verwenden. Ich hab das noch nie ausprobiert.
Wo ist es denn? Opera Browser. Keine Ahnung, ob das was taugt. Opera VPN.
Das ist bestimmt China. China Kinn von KS. Wow. Vielleicht soll ich updaten vorher noch.
Die Leute sind hier schon ganz schön. Irgendeiner ist da ziemlich am Spammen würde ich mal sagen gerade.
Irgendeiner ist da ziemlich am Spammen. Wer ist denn 8, 9, 0, 4, 3, 2, 3? Ich bin es nicht.
Du kannst ruhig weiter spammen. Das ist nicht schlimm.
Ihr solltet alle in EU rauskommen. Ihr solltet alle in EU rauskommen.
Ist ja auch so. Guck mal, es kommt niemand in NA raus. Seht ihr das? Alle kommen nur in EU raus.
Niemand kommt mit in NA raus, weil ihr ja auch nicht in NA seid.
So. Sag mal die IP. Nee, die IP braucht man nicht. Du brauchst NA und dann wirst du richtig aufklösten.
Opera VPN. Wie geht das mit Opera VPN? Hat irgendjemand einen Plan? Ich habe das Ding noch nie verwendet.
China-Chinesen Browser, Alter. Wie geht das? Einstellung? VPN? Aha. Excellent, excellent.
Ah ja, hier, VPN. VPN. So. Optimal Location, Europe, Asia, Americas. Jetzt kommt der Moment der Wahrheit.
Hallo, Kekona. Bam. Es funktioniert, Leute. Hallo, Kekona. Hallo, EU. Guck mal hier. Jetzt kriegen wir auf beide.
Geo-Balanced. Geo-Balanced alles. Hallo, Kekona. Okay, wir können das Ganze testen. Ich mache Europe.
Ah, der hat gecashed. Hallo, EU. Leute, ist das nicht geil? Guck mal. America. Kekona. Umstellen. EU. Hallo, EU.
Richtig poggers, Alter. Richtig poggers. Was bei Asia? Asia gibt es nicht. Ach so, was bei Asia passiert.
Was ist eine gute Frage? Was passiert bei Asia? Äh, Moment. Ich starte. Was passiert bei Asia?
Wahrscheinlich... Na, Closest, sagt der Closest. Closest ist wahrscheinlich dann, je nachdem, wo du in Asia bist. EU. EU.
America. Kekona. Das ist ja geil. Das ist richtig nice. Das ist richtig nice.
Das ist cool. Das gefällt mir. Das gefällt mir richtig gut jetzt, wie das gemacht ist.
Also wir haben zwei Stunden dafür jetzt gebraucht, Leute. Zwei Stunden, man. Aber es ist wirklich nice.
Das gefällt mir unglaublich gut. Kekw.Services.
Eigentlich muss ich jetzt gleich was futtern. Aber eins machen wir jetzt noch. Guck mal.
Also von der Idee her ist jetzt ja zu der Geschichte gar kein allzu großer Akt mehr.
Das hier funktioniert jetzt. Und das hier ist ja im Prinzip eigentlich das vorletzte Mal.
Das heißt, theoretisch können wir einfach... Wir haben das ja letztes Mal richtig gut automatisiert.
Theoretisch können wir einfach Server anlegen und per Ansible deployen.
Das probieren wir mal aus, ob das noch funktioniert, was wir da gebaut haben das letzte Mal.
Warum haben wir da verschiedene Branches dafür überhaupt? Ansible.
Wow. Monka. Ich habe vier Server gebaut. Warum das denn? Vier Stück ist viel zu viel.
Pass mal auf. Jetzt zeige ich euch, wie nice das ist, wenn man das einmalig automatisiert hat.
Okay. Servos. Muss ich jetzt überhaupt anlegen oder hat er die von sich aus angelegt?
Nee, die hat er von sich aus angelegt. Gucke mal da.
Okay, wir machen plus drei Server. Das reicht. Macht 0.2 überhaupt drei oder?
Wir machen nur zwei Server. Das reicht. Gucke mal. Server create NBG1. Das ist Nürnberg wahrscheinlich.
Label CAC WSS Service. Network internal. Warum denn internal?
Ansible Playbook. MonkaS. Ich weiß nicht mal, was ich da gemacht habe. Ja, er ist gerade down.
Ach so. Ah, ich weiß. Network internal wegen Load Balancer davor. Das muss ich erstmal wieder anlegen.
Network internal IP range. Ja, okay. Okay, mal gucken, ob das noch funktioniert, was ich da gebaut habe.
So Ansible Playbook minus EIP Server Jammer. Das heißt, wir müssen jetzt hier nach Ansible gehen.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, ob der Shit funktioniert, den ich hier gebaut habe das letzte Mal.
Jetzt hast du das Network auf EU gestellt. Location habe ich auf EU gestellt. Network auf internal.
Wir gucken mal, ob das jetzt funktioniert. Okay. Klappt das jetzt? Legt er jetzt zwei Server an?
Postchamp, Postchamp. CAC WSS Service 0 und CAC WSS Service 1 ist am Start. IP ist am Start.
Jetzt sollte noch Ansible drauf laufen. Das Ding sollte komplett deployed sein und lauffähig.
Ist das agil? Agilität, Agilität ohne Ende. Aber warum NBG? Warum nicht? Das ist jetzt halt der EU Standort.
Agile, Agil, Agilen ist pur. Ich weiß es halt nicht. Was jetzt?
Kann er Ansible mäßig nicht drauf oder was? Hailed Connect. Das Ding war einfach noch nicht oben.
Unreachable. Ja, das ist einfach noch nicht oben gewesen, das Teil.
Could not connect. Habe ich den SSH Key nicht ausgewählt? Kann das sein?
Wo macht man das hier nachträglich mit den SSH Keys? Gar nicht, oder?
Das hätte so schön funktionieren können. SSH Key, Max Add Poggers.
Welchen Key kann ich sonst da nehmen? Wie nehme ich denn hier sonst immer als Key?
Max Add Poggers. Test Add Test kann ich auch nehmen. Oh nein, fuck. Huch, Glück gehabt.
Moment, Poggers 2? Warum steht da eine 2 dran? Leak, was habe ich denn jetzt schon wieder geleakt?
Ich glaube, ich habe mich hier vertippt. Jetzt habe ich den jetzt schon wieder geleakt, Chat.
Ich glaube. Ich glaube, ich habe mich einfach nur verschrieben. Ich glaube, ich habe mich einfach nur verschrieben.
Das ist alles. Ja, ich habe Poggers 2 geschrieben. Es ist Max Add Poggers. Ich habe mich einfach nur verschrieben.
Sonst nichts. Okay, nochmal. Sleep von 20 auf 30 setzt. Nee, das reicht. Das reicht.
Das war einfach falsche SSH Key eben. Ah, ich habe noch eine Idee. Wir sollten die Dinger...
Nicht CACW as a Service, denn wir sollten die Dinger CACW as a Service...
Oh, was ist denn jetzt schon wieder? Oh Mist, jetzt sind die IPs doppelt drin. Okay, das ist alles nicht so 100% durchdacht, muss ich sagen.
Okay, ich lösche die Dinger jetzt. SSH minus R. Weißt du, was wir jetzt machen? SSH known hosts.
So, jetzt wird alles raus sein, hoffe ich. Ich hätte eigentlich die komplette... Das war es einfach. Bam. Easy.
Okay, jetzt aber. Jetzt aber super Agilitätsaufbaustellen. Ich werde übrigens noch was ändern. In der Hoffnung, es funktioniert dann alles.
Wir nennen die Dinger nicht CACW as a Service. Label? Wofür ist denn das Label? Ah, das Label ist, dass es automatisch ins Loadbalancing reinkommt.
Gell, ich erinnere mich noch. Das heißt, ich brauche jetzt schon einen Loadbalancer dafür, dass es funktioniert.
Okay, create Loadbalancer. Nürnberg. LB1 reicht. Network attached. Wie? Hab ich das falsch angelegt? Die Networks?
Boah, ich bin gerade etwas verwirrt. Warum kann ich im Loadbalancer kein...
Ach, no networks with attached servers. Okay, okay. Also, ich lege jetzt meinen Loadbalancer an. HTTPS. Destination Port 80. Zertifikat. Add Zertifikat.
Das haben wir hier noch am Start. Zertifikat hinzufügen. Abwechselnd. Loadbalancer. Das ist CACW. EU. LB. EU. Und wo ging das mit dem Label jetzt nochmal?
Das ist schon so lange her, wo ich das gemacht habe. Health check. Bait and buy. Das weiß ich gar nicht mehr. Man konnte nämlich sagen, dass der automatisch Targets.
Add Targets. Label. Genau. Und mein Label ist das hier. CACW as a Service. Oder CACW as a Service. Warum habe ich da ein Gleichheitszeichen hinten dran?
Ich baue jetzt wirklich erstmal die Server auf. Allerdings, die Server sollte man... Die muss ich noch ein bisschen umbenennen. Das ist auf jeden Fall CACW as a Service EU. Und das Gleich kann weg.
Das ist bescheuert, dass da noch ein Gleichheitszeichen dran ist. Ach so. Key Value. Deswegen. Aus irgendwelchen Gründen. CACW as a Service EU. Und der Name muss CACW as a Service App. Ich hoffe, das ist nicht zu lang. EU. So. Okay.
Postchamp. Postchamp. Gucken, ob das jetzt klappt, was ich gebaut habe. Postchamp.
Okay. CACW as a Service EU 0 und CACW as a Service EU 1. Das ist doch schonmal gut. Labels. CACW as a Service EU. Okay. Load Balancer. Targets. Targets. Add Targets. Label.
CACW. EU. Add Label Section. Gut. Alles klar. Overview.
Bitch Service EU. Alter. Warum? Warum komme ich da? Was ist das für eine Kacke? Was habe ich falsch gemacht? Das liegt da eindeutig an mir. SSH root add.
Ist der Key falsch, den ich da drin stehen habe? Oder was? Oder wie? Oder hä? Ich bin. Das verstehe ich nicht. Das hat doch das letzte Mal easy funktioniert.
Weg. Aber ich mag das. Ich mag echt das Web Interface. Das finde ich nice. Ich benutze immer den Test Attest. Ja, aber ich habe extra für den Stream so einen Poggers Test Attest. Gucken wir mal. Also wenn es mit dem Test Attest nicht geht, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Poggers 2 war doch richtig. Moment. Moment. Moment. Warte mal. SSH minus. Ich mache jetzt Test Attest als Key. Da weiß ich auf jeden Fall, dass es funktioniert.
Ja, den da. Ich habe keine Ahnung, warum das da nicht funktioniert.
Okay, jetzt aber. Leute, Leute. Oh, nee.
Rege. Ich habe doch nichts an dem Skript geändert. Warum geht das das letzte Mal und jetzt nicht?
Ah, Ansiebele. Es funktioniert. Okay, was sagt meine Feierball? Meine Feier nicht meine Feierball. Was sagt mein Lord Balancer? Mein Lord Balancer sagt healthy. Daubt. X daubt. Wollte ich gerade sagen.
Die Anwendung ist doch nicht mal deployed. Wie soll die healthy sein?
Da habe ich so meine Zweifel dran.
So was wir übrigens gerade machen, weil wir bauen gerade den hier auf Lord Balancer und zwei. Es ist nicht drei. Es sind zwei Nutzen und zwei Absorber für die EU dahinter.
Eigentlich Leute, eigentlich müssten wir jetzt während er gerade aufbaut. Eigentlich müssten wir noch Folgendes machen. Oh, man. Eigentlich müssten wir noch 5 geschoben. Auch okay. Eigentlich müssten wir noch Folgendes machen.
Kekona ist das Service. Kekwe ist das Service. Eigentlich muss da noch Kekona rein. Also ihr seht, die Anwendung ist relativ minimalistisch. Http get. So und eigentlich brauchen wir aber auch auf jeden Fall noch get Kekona.
Hallo. Kannst mal Einrückung machen. Was ist hier los?
Gravuzzi. Danke für den Sub. Get Kekona slash.
Wobei das mache ich jetzt nicht. Ich will jetzt nicht an der Anwendung noch was puddeln. Okay. Was macht mein Lord Balancer? Service. Erster Service ist da. Erster Service ist da. Easy. Easy. Easy.
Erster Service ist da. Das heißt, hier bekomme ich schon was. Ach nee. Zertifikat. Erster Service ist da. Lord Balancer. Zweiter Service ist da. Gut. Nice.
Okay. Das heißt, ich muss jetzt auf meinem DNS umstellen. Ich muss jetzt auf meinem DNS die Lord Balancer IP einstellen für EU. Also Lord Balancer IP für EU ist das da.
Und den DNS starten. Und den DNS starten. Und jetzt Dick.
Das ist nicht wie es ist. Gs. Gs. Ist das jetzt richtige IP? Jawohl. Okay. Also testen wir mal. Gs. Kekw. Services.
Zack. Da ist es Leute. Gültiges Zertifikat. Gültiges Zertifikat. Gs. Kekw. Services.
Wir können jetzt noch eine Weiterleitung machen. Was ist denn das? Alias? Nee. C Name? Wie kann ich jetzt eine DNS Weiterleitung machen, dass das, dass die Route, das Route auf
Gs. Kekw geht? So oder?
Da bin ich jetzt zu unfähig für. Da bin ich jetzt zu unfähig für. Wie macht man das jetzt?
Das Value ist die IP? Nee, das kann nicht sein, dass Value die IP ist bei einem Alias.
Okay. Wir machen hier einen Wildcard für den.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich habe nur NS Records. Ich habe keinen. Oder das da? Nee. Ich will ein C Name. Ich will eigentlich, dass Kekw auf Gs zeigt.
Okay, dafür bin ich zu großer DNS Noob. Keine Ahnung, wie das funktioniert. Aber warum machst du DNS Einträge? Weil das Default ist. Weil, weil der ja zuständig ist für die Domain.
Das ist standardmäßig so drin. Okay, dann bin ich zu. Zu Kekw für keinen Schimmer, wie das jetzt klappt.
Einfach leer lassen? Nee, ich glaube, ich glaube, das geht nicht einfach leer lassen.
Keine Ahnung, wie das funktioniert. Ich will, ich will, dass Kekw.Services automatisch weiterleitet auf Gs.
Das ist jetzt nicht unser Ziel. Unser Ziel ist, dass wir Lord Balancer und Gedöns haben, auch in den USA.
So, das haben wir jetzt hier hinbekommen. Also in EU, in EU funktioniert der ganze Shit ja schon mal. Guckt, EU klappt alles. Gs.Kekw.Services. Alles gut hier.
Könnt ihr hier refreshen und gucken und machen und tun. Passt alles. Wir haben das insofern sogar ausfallsicher gemacht. Wir haben den Lord Balancer am Start mit zwei Abservern dahinter. Muss so aussehen.
Du? Nee, oder? Wirklich? Der Umochi baitet mich. Ich probiere das jetzt trotzdem aus. So?
Okay, ich bin da zu blöd für. Wie haben wir das denn im letzten Stream gemacht? Im letzten Mal haben wir keinen C-Name. Im letzten Mal hatten wir A-Records gemacht.
Ich glaube, ich bin da zu Pepega für. Ich weiß nicht, wie der Kram funktioniert.
Weiterleiten geht nicht. Nee, C-Name record points your host into another domain. Ja, das ist doch genau das, was ich will. C-Name? Gut.
Why a domain should can't be a C-Name? Aha. Haha. Das geht nicht. Das geht nicht. Das ist nicht erlaubt. Get wrecked.
Toss. Das geht nicht. Okay, das wusste ich nicht. Aber DNS ist eh so ein Buch mit 7 Siegeln. Das heißt, was ich jetzt eigentlich machen müsste, ist ein Redirect oder so.
Also ich müsste jetzt quasi irgendwie einen Loadbalancer da hinstellen oder irgendwas und dann Redirect machen auf das andere. Ja, okay, dann, ganz ehrlich, dann können wir mit gs.keqw.services leben.
Warum ich das überhaupt mit Subdomain gemacht habe, so hier, ich habe das mit Subdomain gemacht, dass die Top-Level-Domain hier bleibt, weil dann können die Loadbalancer automatische Zertifikate ausstellen und sowas.
Deswegen wollte ich das hier als Subdomain haben. Und jetzt hätte ich es ja auch als Top-Level-Domain machen können. Okay. Ja, wenn ich das, also sprich, wenn ich das als Top-Level-Domain weiter verwenden will, du kannst eigenen DNS auch die root-Domain. Will ich ja gar nicht. Will ich ja gar nicht.
Wofür steht das gs? Chat, ich habe es schon wieder vergessen. Für was hatten wir das als Abkürzung genommen? Global-Stels oder sowas? Irgendwas bescheuertes. Das gs steht für nichts Sinnvolles. Geostels, genau, unsinniger Kram.
Gearscore. Gamerscore hatten wir noch. Gamerscore hatten wir noch auf der Xbox. So, okay, also wir haben unsere Loadbalancer aufgebaut für EU. Jetzt bauen wir noch unsere Loadbalancer auf für NA, dass wir diese Sache hier hinkriegen.
Da muss ich mal gucken, ob ich das jetzt dynamisch genug gemacht habe, dass es funktioniert. Oh, ups. So, also.
So, also wir bauen jetzt zwei Server auf in NA. Location Name. Tja, Hetzner, NBG 1. Wie ist die richtige Location Name? NBG für Ash.
Ash. Wie heißt der Kram? Ash. Das steht doch noch gar nicht drinnen. Massive Tibet.
Ash. El Sinki. Die stehen da noch gar nicht drinnen. Lass mich raten, Ash 1 ist das Datacenter.
Ash 1 dachte ich mir. Ich rate jetzt einfach mal. Ash 1 ist es wahrscheinlich. Das ist bestimmt Ash 1. Wir probieren das jetzt einfach aus. Sollte Ash minus DC 1 sein?
Location Ash 1. Okay, haben wir das jetzt richtig? Moment, der Loadbalancer stimmt so nicht. Network Internal ist natürlich auch Fail.
Das stimmt nicht. Ah, okay, das muss man. Dann muss man noch ein zweites Netzwerk anlegen. Klar, das ist ja EU.
Das heißt eigentlich müsste ich das umbenennen, falls man das umbenennen darf. Internal EU müssten wir das umbenennen. Network Updated.
Und jetzt brauchen wir noch ein Network Internal NA, weil das ist in US East. Okay, also jetzt legen wir Server NA an.
Network NA. Okay, passt. Lassen wir es einfach mal aufbauen. Ash Not Found. Okay, was ist es? Location einfach nur Ash, nicht 1. Einfach nur Ash.
Was? Name is already in use? But why? Name is already in use. Ich hab den Namen nicht geändert. No host matched.
NA. He doesn't know. Siehste, deswegen hat man Parameter normalerweise bei so einem Skript, dass man nicht die Hälfte vergisst.
Okay, und jetzt NA 0. Warum liegt da nur NA 0 an, nicht NA 1? Server Limit Exceeded. Nein, nein, wir können es nicht ausprobieren. Ich hab zu viele Server.
Moment, den brauchen wir doch gar nicht, oder? Den brauchen wir. Der ist doch einfach nur random da. Moment, der ist einfach nur random da. Den brauchen wir doch gar nicht, oder Leute? Nee, den brauchen wir nicht.
Der ist einfach nur da zum ausprobieren gewesen. Der ist bloated. Okay, den hier müssen wir umbenennen.
KekW DNS, da ich im Endeffekt noch weiß, was es ist. Okay, haben wir den DNS am Start. Jetzt ist Facebook down.
So, und jetzt führen wir das Ganze nochmal aus. Ich lösche den wieder. KekW as a Service NA. Ich hoffe, ich darf dann überhaupt noch einen Load Balancer anlegen.
Oh, hab ich jetzt ausgeführt schon. Ja, jetzt baut er auf. Also, KekW as a Service NA 1, KekW as a Service NA 0. Wunderbar. In Ashburn sind wir am Start.
Übrigens, Leute, wo wir gerade dabei sind. Dieser Stream heute ist gesponsort von Hetzner. Ausrufezeichen Hetzner im Chat.
Könnt ihr euch einen 20 Euro Startgutscheincode für die Hetzner Cloud sichern. Und ihr seht schon, mit 20 Euro kommt man hier eigentlich relativ weit. Kleine Kiste, 4 Euro im Monat, statische IPv4 Adresse.
Gut, IPv6, klar, kostet ja nix. Stundliche Abrechnung. Und ihr könnt beispielsweise mit dem Startgutschein ohne Probleme hier, sag mal ungefähr, ja, sagen wir zweieinhalb Monate, könnt ihr eine Triple Core Kiste dann umsonst laufen lassen.
Die sollen ja mal ein größeres Limit sponsoren. Das ist relativ easy. Du musst einfach den Support anschreiben, dann geht das schnell. Okay, Loadbalancer hinzufügen.
Create Loadbalancer in Ashburn, Internal NA, Targets, Label, Keqv, LB, NA. Ach Quatsch, nee. Was war das Label? Keqv.
Keqv, nein. Label, Keqv, SSS, NA. Zwei Stück, down. Passt, Loadbalancer, Health Check, HTTPS, Source, 443, Certificate, das Keqv-Certificate-Card.
Source-Port, 443. Übrigens, ich habe auch keine Health-Checks an, so richtig. Ich habe extra einen Slash-Health-Check. Ich weiß nicht, warum das Rofi-7 schon wieder light ist.
Name, Loadbalancer, hab ich hier nicht umbenannt? Ach nee, hier unten. Das Ding heißt Keqv, LB, NA, Create.
Jawoll, da sind wir, da sind wir. Jetzt müssen wir nämlich noch die IP im DNS ändern. Serveraufbau scheint ja funktioniert zu haben.
IP im DNS ändern. Und dann haben wir es, glaube ich, geschafft. Und dann mache ich noch mal kurz einen Recap, falls noch nicht alle so mitbekommen haben, was jetzt eigentlich passiert ist.
So, also von der Idee her sollte das jetzt eigentlich funktionieren. Wir haben quasi genau dieses Setup hier, was wir gemacht haben. Loadbalancer in Europa, zwei Applikationsserver dahinter.
Loadbalancer, zwei Applikationsserver dahinter in Nordamerika. Wir haben den eigenen DNS, der Anfragen von EU-User zu dem Loadbalancer in der EU auflöst und Anfragen von NA-User zu dem Loadbalancer in NA.
Die Sache ist plus die, wir erkennen jetzt nicht wirklich, ob es funktioniert, weil die Seite überall gleich aussieht. Aber es hat ja vorher auch funktioniert.
So, was machen die Loadbalancer? NA? Alle da? Ok. Exclusive. Dann checken wir das doch jetzt mal. Also, GS-Services.
Zack. VPN. Wir sind in Amerika. Also, wir bekommen jetzt die Antwort aus NA. Und wenn ich jetzt umschalte auf EU, bekommen wir die Antwort von dem Server Cluster in EU.
Wie können wir denn jetzt nachgucken? Kann man hier irgendwie... Kann ich irgendwie sehen? Im Netzwerk? Kann man im Netzwerk-Dings irgendwie sehen, was die...
Ne, wahrscheinlich nicht, oder? Was da ausgeliefert wird? Kann ich jetzt sehen, wie das auflöst hier über VPN? Weil der Service schreibt ja das Gleiche hin.
Ich will wissen, was für eine Antwort... Meint ihr, das steht hier in den Tools drinnen bei Netzwerk? Was die Absender-IP ist? Erdas? Remote Address.
Ne, das ist meine. Oder? Weder noch. Ach, ich hab Europe eingestellt. Ok, ok. Ich hab Europe eingestellt. Also, Remote 7.7.1. Und jetzt stellen wir NA ein. Alter. Ah, was ist das für ein Kack?
Monka! Network? Zack. Ok. Remote Address 7.7.1.1. Irgendwas? Das, was meine ist. Oh, das ist meine. Das ist mein Request, das ist mein Request. Server, ich brauch die Server-Adress.
Ich brauch die Server-Adress. Sieht man die Server-Adress dann nicht?
F-Tools. Server-IP. Äh, ins Log ist tatsächlich... Ah, das kann man einplanten lassen. Guck mal.
Remote Address. Bam. Wo ist es jetzt? Ah, DevTools, please.
Hä? Ah, aber das bin doch ich. Das bin doch ich.
Hä? Wie macht man das? Was für ein...
Hm. Ich hab keine Ahnung. Ja, aber... Warum ist Remote Address denn ich und nicht der Server? Proxen die das irgendwie oder so? Kann das sein, dass sie das irgendwie proxen?
Gut, ich mein... Die, ich glaub, die Proxen, das irgendwie, die VPN-Dudes. So, gut. Dann machen wir das jetzt anders, um rauszubekommen, was das ist. Wir gucken jetzt einfach auf die Server drauf. Easy.
Zack. Ähm. Nee, wir können... Schreib ich überhaupt Logs auf den Servern? Ich vergess nicht, ob ich auch Logs auf den Servern schreib.
Äh, lass mal kurz nachgucken. Also, ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass es funktioniert, ja. Aber... 100% nicht wissen tun, was nicht. Remote Add.
Wo, wohin deploye ich diesen Kram überhaupt? Okay, wir müssen mal an unser Ansible reingucken. Äh, KekWay Service. Oh, Ansible. Wohin deploy ich den Kram überhaupt?
Ja. Home, App, KekWay Service. Okay. Gibt's irgendwelche Logs oder so? Nein, natürlich nicht.
Log der Nacht... Nee, das... Ach, keine Ahnung. Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie ich das rauskriege.
Das Outparra-VPN ist halt der Sack. Der Proxy den Kram irgendwie. Deswegen seh ich das nicht.
Gut, wir können die Anwendung einfach anpassen. Wir passen die Anwendung, wir passen... Nee, ich kann die Anwendung... Alter, ich hab das zu big brain gemacht.
Ich hab die Anwendung ja statisch kompili... Also, ich kann die Anwendung nicht mal auf den Server anpassen.
Nehmen wir den richtigen VPN und pingen den Server im Terminal an. Nee, das ist funktioniert, weiß ich ja. Das ist funktioniert, weiß ich ja. Ich hab ja von meinem A-Server aufgelöst.
Ich wollte euch jetzt einfach noch mal abschließend die IP hier drin zeigen, aber das funktioniert mit diesem kack Outparra-VPN anscheinend nicht.
Dann halt nicht. Aber wir haben es ja davor gemacht und dann hat das alles funktioniert. Ich mein, doch, doch, ich kann euch beweisen, dass es funktioniert. Ich kann euch beweisen, dass es funktioniert. Ganz einfach.
Guckt mal. Also, das hier ist jetzt... Das ist jetzt Verbindung NA und das ist jetzt Verbindung EU. So, geht beides. Jetzt mach ich einfach die Verbindung NA aus.
Nee, unpingen, unpingen bringt nix, bringt nix. Also, wir könnten, wir könnten übers VPN irgendeinen Ping, in Remote irgendeinen Ping über VPN machen oder so. Ja, das könnten wir machen.
Ping. Alle akzeptieren. Ihre IP-V4-Adresse ist nicht vorhanden. Auch geil.
Okay. Ping online. Wobei das, das funktioniert auch nicht gescheit. Nee, ich zeige euch jetzt, wie ich das vorhabe. Also, wir sind, wir sind hier über EU drinne.
Jetzt sind wir in Amerika drinne. So, ich werde jetzt einfach ausschalten NA und ihr werdet sehen, es funktioniert. Also EU funktioniert weiterhin, aber NA ist weg.
Was das für eine Hintergrundmusik ist, irgendeine Playlist. So, also, wir machen das jetzt einfach. Den Load Balancer schalten wir einfach aus, falls man den Mopf ausschalten kann.
Wir schalten jetzt den NA Load Balancer aus. Geht das überhaupt? Kann man den irgendwie deaktivieren?
Ich meine, ich kann das Label rausnehmen.
Was hier? Results. Ah ja, hier, hier, das ist, das ist eine gute Seite. Guckt mal, jetzt, jetzt kann ich euch beweisen, dass der Gram funktioniert.
Mal hier wieder rein. Add Targets, Label, Pack W, NA, Add Label. Jetzt kann ich euch zeigen, dass es funktioniert. Hier, immer die Results, die der Sarex gepostet hat.
Genau, guckt, aus Toronto und aus Fremont oder sowas kriegen wir die IP und aus Johannesburg. Kann man das nicht irgendwie aus EU machen oder so?
Was, was, was, was, was es alles für Tools gibt, Alter, habe ich so noch nie gesehen. Kann man, kann man hier, kann man einfach so pingen? Wo ist denn hier der Ping, Ping Knopf, Ping, Ping?
EU kommt man auch die 162 Adresse. Ja, das ist ja auch richtig. Also es funktioniert auf jeden Fall. So, und das Nice ist, ah ja, übrigens aus, aus Asien kriegt man dann wahrscheinlich die Europe IP.
Oh, Asien ist ziemlich langsam. Ohje, ohje, aus Asien ist langsam. Ping.EU. Jetzt, jetzt wird es advanced. Ping.EU.
Das sind alles so krasse Chibates, Chibates. Europe. NA. Hab ich alles noch nie ausprobiert. NA. Ping. Ach, hier ist der Test, okay.
Machen wir es lieber hier mit. OPN. Amerikas. Genau, also GS.CACW.Services. Ping Now. Ah, das ist, kommt der Kram, genau. Guckt, und der Vorteil ist, leider hat er keine, leider haben die keine EU Server.
Leider haben die keine EU Server. Der Vorteil davon ist jetzt auch relativ offensichtlich. Guckt mal, wir haben unter 100 Millisekunden Response Time in NA und unter 100 Millisekunden Response Time aus EU.
Es ist halt nicht EU. Man könnte jetzt ohne Probleme noch Asier einfügen. Also wenn jetzt CACW.Services so der riesen krasse Renner wird, könnte ich jetzt relativ easy hergehen und einfach sagen DNS.
DNS. CACW.Services. Da könnte ich hier quasi einfach eintragen, noch einen Server in Asien oder so und dann geht das.
Das kann ich mit Hetzner in dem Fall jetzt hier gerade nicht machen, weil ich glaube die haben keine Server. Du hast ja nur diese vier Rechenzentren.
Aber das ist eigentlich eine coole Geschichte. Also funktioniert. Das hat, das hat gut geklappt und es hat sich mal wieder ausgezahlt, dass wir den Kram automatisiert haben.
Das hat sich auch richtig ausgezahlt, dass wir den Kram automatisiert haben, weil wir haben jetzt hier ein Cluster. Es ist nicht wirklich ein Cluster. Es ist eigentlich zwei unabhängige Server mit Load Balancer davor.
A, zwei unabhängige Server mit Load Balancer davor EU. Dann DNS. Der Auflösung macht je nach geografischer Lage. Und dann kann man CACW im Kreis drehen lassen.
Richtig nice. Erfolgreicher Stream. Leute, ich hab Hunger. Ich muss was essen gehen. Ich hoffe euch hat der Stream gefallen.
Wenn ihr auch Interesse habt sowas zu machen, guckt mal bei Hetzner vorbei. Ausrufezeichen Hetzner im Chat.
Könnt ihr euch mal ein Startgutscheincode sichern. Und wer es gefallen hat kann natürlich auch seinen Prime-Sub dalassen. Das wäre natürlich exquisite. Wenn wir noch any Primers hätten. Und guckt gerade wen ich hosten kann.
Hat euch der Stream gefallen, Leute. Jetzt mal so. Ich hoffe natürlich, dass jetzt alle sagen ja und ich nicht hier so eine Kacke oder so. Und gucken wen ich hosten kann.
Guter Stream. Nice Stream. Orgas station. Lost spielt Apex. Wir hosten den Lost. Den hab ich schon eine Weile nicht mehr gehostet.
Oder Raiden. Raiden tut man ja heutzutage. Flash Raid Lost. Leute, danke für die Subs. Scotcho und Johnny Bordello ist am Start. 21 natürlich. Warum nicht 69? Das hätte auch deutlich besser gepasst.
Raiden wir mal den Lost. Und ich geh jetzt was essen. War richtig cooler Stream. Hat mir auch Spaß gemacht. Ab und zu Sellout muss sein. Ich denke mal Hetzner hat da auch gut was von. Das war ja echt.
Vermutlich mal eine informative Geschichte. Hat sicherlich die ein oder andere Leute aufmerksam gemacht. Und wir sehen uns Leute. Bis denn. Machts gut. C U